AND GET STARTED IN HOPE THAT MY
VICE CHAIR IS ON HIS WAY HERE --
AS ALWAYS THERE ARE NUMBER OF US
WHEN THE IN HOME TO KIDS.
AND HE HAS THE RECORDS WELL I
CAN GET THROUGH THE HOUSEKEEPING
PORTION.
SO GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO
THE MAY SIXTEENTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS SUSPENSE HEARING
ON ASSEMBLY BILLS.
WE HAVE SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ONE BILLS ON THE SUSPENSE FILE.
WHICH I'D LIKE TO NOTE IS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE BILLS
MORE THAN WE CONSIDERED LAST
YEAR AT THIS TIME AND MORE BILLS.
THAN THIS COMMITTEE HAS
CONSIDERED IN ONE HEARING AN
OVER AT LEAST A DECADE.
I'D LIKE TO THINK MY VICE CHAIR
OFFERS COOPERATION MOVING THESE
HEARINGS FORWARD THANK YOU
MISTER BIGELOW.
SHOWING UP WITH.
READY TO GO.
I ALSO WANT TO AND THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR HARD WORK
ON THE BILLS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND FINALLY -- I'D LIKE TO HELP.
REALLY THINK THE APPROPRIATIONS
STAFF AND REPUBLICAN FISCAL
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE
ANALYZED AND MANAGE THIS YEAR'S
RECORD NUMBER OF BILLS WITH ONE
LAST WEEK THAN IN PRIOR YEARS
DURING WHICH TO COMPLETE THEIR
WORK.
SO THANK YOU TO THE STAFF.
OUR LAST COUPLE MONTHS WE'VE
MOVIE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
BILLS TO SUSPENSE AND NOW IT'S
TIME TO DISPENSE OF THEM.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT
THE BILL PACKETS ARE DIVIDED BY
SUBJECT AREA IN OUR VEIL FULL
ONLINE AT THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IS
WEBSITE WHICH IS LOCATED AT
EIGHT P. R. O..
DOT ASSEMBLY DOT C. EIGHT DOT
GOP.
LATER THIS AFTERNOON FOLLOWING
TODAY'S HEARING THE COMMITTEE
WILL POST THE RESULTS OF THE
SUSPENSE FILE HEARING ON THAT
SAME WEBSITE.
MR BIGELOW IS THERE ANYTHING YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SAY BEFORE WE GET
STARTED.
I WOULD JUST.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK THE
STAFF AND THE CHAIR IN
PARTICULAR FOR WORKING WITH ALL
THE DIFFERENT PARTIES WHO.
ARE AFFECTED MANY OF THE BILL
AUTHORS -- HAVE BEEN VERY
COURTEOUS AND RESPECTFUL AND
WHILE IT HAS BEEN CHALLENGING
FOR US TO WORK THROUGH THIS
DYNAMIC -- LEVEL OF WORKLOAD --
WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO EACH
OF US YOU THE AUTHORS FOR
WORKING WITH US AND ALSO THE
PEOPLE OUT IN THE OTHER PART OF
THE WORLD.
WHO WORK AND HAVE A?
THEY HAVE A SENTIMENT TOWARDS
THESE BILLS SO ANYWAY THANK YOU.
MINIATURE.
VIDEO -- I WANNA REMIND -- THE
MEMBERS AS THEY'RE WATCHING WE
DID TALK ABOUT SOME OF THIS BUT
THEIR NUMBER OF THINGS THAT ARE
A LITTLE DIFFERENT THIS YEAR.
A LOT OF BILLS THAT YOU WOULD
ASSUME WHERE IN A CERTAIN
SUBJECT AREA MAYBE MUHTAR
GENERAL GOVERNMENT AREA THE LAST
READING OF THE LAST OF BILLS
THAT WERE TAKING UP.
SO AT IF YOU DON'T HEAR YOUR
BILL YOU MAY LOOK FOR THEIR THE
OTHER THING THAT WE'LL TALK
ABOUT AT THE END IS THOSE BILLS
WHO ARE NOT CALLED OUT TODAY AND
WE'LL DEAL WITH THAT AT THE END
OF THE HEARING [inaudible]
STARTING WAGES [inaudible]
WELL.
WHAT I WAS GOING BACK TO THE
SCRIPT?
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA.
ROW.
CALDERON CARRILLO SEND THINGS
OUT HERE DEEP.
EGGMAN FONG GABRIEL.
GARCIA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS.
WORK HERE RIVAS [inaudible]
WE ARE.
GOING TO START WITH EDUCATION
AND I THINK EVERYBODY HAS A
DOCUMENT IN FRONT OF THEM OUR
FIRST BILL AB.
WE WILL TAKE A MOTION IN JUST A
MOMENT AB TWO SANTIAGO
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO LIMIT
PROGRAM TO STUDENTS AND THEIR
SECOND YEAR.
SPECIFY THE MEANING OF A FULL
TIME STUDENT AT A REPORT MOTION
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK IN A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO.
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
SUBSTITUTE THAT MOTION AND
SECOND FOR ALL DO PASS OR DO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS ON THE
REST OF THE SUSPENSE FILE.
ALL RIGHT READY.
AB SIX REYES EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION BRANCH DO PASS GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL AB EIGHT TO
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
SCHOOLS TO PASS AMENDED TO SHIP
FUNDS TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
ACT CHANGE RATIO TO ONE
PROFESSIONAL PER SIX HUNDRED
STUDENTS AND CHANGE AN ADMIN
DATE.
CREDENTIAL REQUIREMENTS THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING AB FIFTEEN IS THERE
IN CHILDREN SAVINGS ACCOUNTS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE
CERTAIN BIRTH DATA INSTEAD BIRTH
CERTIFICATES.
MAKE CHANGES TO AGE REQUIREMENTS
AND VARIOUS OTHER TECHNICAL
MEHMET SACKETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB SIXTEEN THREE OF US.
HOMELESS YOUTH COORDINATORS DO
PASS THAT GETS ON A ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY BERMAN COMPETE CALIFORNIA
COMPUTER SCIENCE COORDINATOR
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OBERNOLTE STATE
SEAL STEM.
DO YOU PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB
THIRTY HOLDEN COLLEGE CAREER IN
ACCESS PATHWAYS TO PASS AS A
MANAGEMENT REPORT DEADLINE TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTY NIGHTMARE CG LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA TO PASS.
WHICH ONE THAT WAS AB.
THIRTY NINE SAID SHE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA TO PASS.
WAIT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
WE'LL GET BACK TO THAT -- ONE
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY.
AB FORTY EIGHT O'DONNELL CAN
GUARD A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITIES BOND DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE CERTAIN PRE
SCHOOL FACILITIES AT A MATCHING
REQUIREMENT TO LEAD PROGRAM STEP
PROGRAM.
AND SAID THE TWENTY TWENTY BOND
AMOUNT AT THIRTEEN BILLION.
AB FORTY EIGHT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB FIFTY TWO BERMAN COMPUTER
SCIENCE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB ONE TWENTY
THREE MCCARTY PRE K. FOR ALL ACT
DO PASS.
ON A B. ROLL CALL AB ONE TWENTY
FOUR MCCARTY LOCAL CHILD CARE
PLANNING COUNCILS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
AB ONE THIRTY LOW.
HIGHER EDUCATION PERFORMANCE
ACCOUNTABILITY DO PASS ON ANY
ROLL CALL AB ONE FIFTY FOUR
VOEPEL INCOME SHARE AGREEMENTS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB ONE EIGHTY
TWO THREE OF US COMPUTER SCIENCE
CREDENTIAL WORKGROUP HOLDING
COMMUNITY.
AB ONE NINETY SEVEN WEBER FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN DO PASSES
AMENDED TO REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO
OFFER AT LEAST ONE FULL DAY
PROGRAM THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
AB TWO TWO ONE CRISTINA GARCIA
THIRD PARTY TEACHER CONTRACTS TO
PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL AB TWO
THIRTY SIX EDUARDO GARCIA FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTERS ON
DISABILITY DO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL.
AB TWO FIFTY EIGHT JONES SAWYER
SCHOOL BASED PEOPLE SUPPORT
SERVICES TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
AB TWO NINETY SEVEN GALLAGHER
EMERGENCY AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
AB THREE OH TWO BERMAN PARKING
FOR HOMELESS STUDENTS TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTY THREE THIRTY ONE AMET
MEDINA ETHNIC STUDIES HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION REQUIREMENT DO
PASSING A B. ROLL CALL.
AB THREE FIFTY FOUR QUIRK SILVA.
SCHOOL MEAL OVERSIGHT TO PASS ON
TO BE ROLL CALL AB THREE SIXTY
NINE WEBER MERIT SALARY
pADJUSTMENTS FOR CSU SUPPORT
STAFF TO PASS ON AB ROLL CALL.
AB THREE NINETY SIX EGGMAN
SCHOOL SOCIAL WORK PILOT PROGRAM
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB FOR TWENTY
EIGHT MEDINA SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB FOR FIFTY TWO MULLIN CHILD
CARE FACILITY GRANTS TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL AB FOR SIXTY THREE
CERVANTES COMING COLLEGE FACULTY
LOAN FORGIVENESS TO PASS ON TO
BE ROLL CALL. 847-9 IS THERE IN
PLANT BASED FOOD AND BEVERAGE
PROGRAM DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CAP REIMBURSEMENT TO THREE
MILLION PRIOR TRIS GRANTS LOW
INCOME SCHOOLS NECK IT'S OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL.
AB FOR NINETY THREE GLORIA LGBT
Q. TEACHER TRAINING TO PASS AS
AMENDED REQUIRES SEEDEATER
DEVELOP AN ONLINE TRAINING
PROVIDE GRANTS REQUIRE TRAINING
EVERY TWO YEARS THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB FIVE HUNDRED GONZALEZ PAID
MATERNITY LEAVE YOU PASS ON A
ROLL CALL AB FIVE A FIVE
PATTERSON BOOK ADVANCE PROGRAM
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB FIVE TWENTY
ONE BERMAN FIRE PREVENTION
TRAINING TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB FIVE THIRTY TWO WEBER CSU
PARKING FAIRNESS ACT HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB FIVE FORTY LOW MOAN
SERVICE INSTEAD OF GRANT PROGRAM
TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL AB
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT MULLIN STEM
TEACHING PATHWAYS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
AB SIX TWELVE WEBER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE RESTAURANT MEALS PROGRAM
TO PASS AND IN A ROLL CALL.
AB SIX SIX SIX GABRIEL PEOPLE
MENTAL HEALTH PROTOCOLS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
AB SEVEN TWENTY MURATSUCHI
INSTRUCTIONAL SERVICE AGREEMENTS
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB SEVEN
FIFTY ONE O'DONNELL PATHWAYS
COLLEGE ACT TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL.
AB SEVEN SEVEN THREE GONZALEZ
VOTER EDUCATION FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE LANGUAGE INFORMATION
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AB SEVEN SEVENTY SIX KALRA
PEOPLE IDENTIFIERS FOR CHILD
CARE TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE BLOOM
DOCTORED OF OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB EIGHT FORTY TWO THE MOAN
CHILD CARE AND PRE SCHOOL MEALS
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB EIGHT
FORTY THREE RODRIGUEZ ASSUMPTION
PROGRAM FOR AT OF LOANS FOR
EDUCATION.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO REMOVE
APPROPRIATIONS MAKE.
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION AND
MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL NEMECHEK
IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB EIGHT FIFTY TWO BURKE CONTENT
STANDARD UPDATES TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL.
AB EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE WICKS IN
SCHOOL SUPPORT SERVICES TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL.
AB NINE EIGHTEEN SMITH MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB NINE THIRTY GLORIA
CSU EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION
REPORTING TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE BI ANNUAL REPORTING THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB NINE SIXTY THREE
PETRIE-NORRIS POST SECONDARY
VOTER EMPOWERMENT PROGRAM TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
STUDENTS IN PLANNING EVENTS
TICKETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB NINE SIXTY SEVEN SMITH LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS GET.
DO YOU PASSED THAT GETS OUT OF
THE ROLL CALL.
AB TEN TWELVE RADIUS BILINGUAL
PROGRAMS HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB TEN
FIFTY ONE SMITH CLINICAL NURSING
FACULTY TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
AB TEN SEVENTY FIVE HOLDEN
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY.
LOGY DO PASS AS AMENDED REMOVE
THE PREPARATION THAT COULD
HAPPEN IN A ROLL CALL. 1-081-
GALLAGHER AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM
UNSPENT FUNDS HOLDING COMMITTEE
AB TEN EIGHTY FIVE MCCARTY AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND CANNABIS
REVIEW TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TEN EIGHTY SEVEN CUNNINGHAM
FINANCIAL LITERACY HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB TEN NINETY SEVEN
HOLDEN CREDIT RICK.
RECOVERY REPORT DO PASSES
MINUTES REQUIRE SPECIFIED
INFORMATION MOVE DEADLINE THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB ELEVEN NINETEEN EDUARDO
GARCIA A SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX O'DONNELL
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB ELEVEN FIFTY THREE
WICKS MANDATED REPORTER TRAINING
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO FRAZIER
NON PUBLIC SCHOOL OVERSIGHT TO
PASS ON ANY ROLL CALL.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
O'DONNELL CENTER TO COSE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPSHOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
AB ELEVEN NINETY SIX GIPSON
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY SCHOOLS ACT
TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
AB TWELVE FOURTEEN LANDIS CPR
TRAINING DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE CERTAIN PERSONNEL
WITHOUT CPR CERTIFICATION TO BE
PRESENT ON CAMPUS ATHLETIC
EVENTS SUCH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING THAT GETS OUT WITHIN
A ROLL CALL.
AB TWELVE NINETEEN JONES SAWYER
TEACHER MRS SIGN AT MONITORING
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWELVE THIRTY THREE SMITH
ADVANCED PLACEMENT EXAMINATION
FEES DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE THE FIVE DOLLAR EXAM FEE
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN OH THREE A DONALD
CREE TECHNICAL EDUCATION GRATZ
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN BLANCA
RUBIO CAL GRANTS TO NONPROFIT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN THIRTEEN LIST THREE
OF US DEBT COLLECTION TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN MEDINA CAL
GRANT REFORM DO PASSES AMENDED
TO PHASE IN REFORMS OVER TWO
YEARS BACK TO TOP WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY TWO GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT RULE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
AS HELL TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE BERMAN FOR
CAUGHT PROFIT COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY NOTIFICATION AND
APPROVAL THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL.
AB FOUR T..
AB THIRTEEN FORTY TWO LOW SALE
NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS TO PASS
ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE EGGMAN
FOR PROFIT COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY STUDENT WOMAN TWO
PASSES MINUTES DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION BY YEAR THAT GETS
OUT OF THE ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR OF OUR
QUE HAN OUT OF STATE COLLEGE
UNIVERSITY REGISTRATION TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX MEDINA
STUDENT TUITION RECOVERY FUND TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR GIPSON
JUVENILE COURT SCHOOL STUDENT
PLANNING TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ALLOW MORE TIME FOR DATA
TRANSFER AND OTHER TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS ACT IT'S OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE MCCARTY
IN MISSION BY EXCEPTION TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY THREE WEBER
LAOTIAN MODEL CURRICULA DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL AB FOURTEEN TEN
QUIRK SILVA COMPUTER SCIENCE
TRAINING AUTHORIZATIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO STRIKE
APPROPRIATIONS LIKE IT'S OUT ON
A ROLL CALL.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY WEBER ETHNIC
STUDIES IT'S YES YOU DO PASS ON
TO BE ROLL CALL AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY SIX IRWIN STATEWIDE
DATABASE TASK FORCE TO PASS ON
IT A ROLL CALL.
AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE O'DONNELL
CHARTER SCHOOL PETITIONS TO PASS
ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AB FIFTY NO SIX MCCARTY TERSE
ONE OPERATION AUTHORIZATION
ENROLLMENT DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE STATEWIDE SCHOOL CAP
ALLOW ELEAZAR WITH LESS THAN 10%
CHARTER MOMENT. TO OPEN CHARTERS
AND PROVIDE A ROLLING CAP TO
ALLEYS WITH MORE THAN 10%
CHARTER ENROLLMENT PROVIDE
PRIORITY TO NON CHARTER
MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATIONS.
JACKETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS IS
ABSTAINING.
AB FIFTEEN AWAY BONTA BREAKFAST
AFTER THE BELL HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT THREE
OF US SCHOOL PAVEMENT TO PARKS
PROGRAM TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ENCOURAGE TREES AND GREEN SPACE
THAT COULD HAPPEN IN A ROLL CALL.
AB SIXTY NO SIX GRAY SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY SCHOOL OF MEDICINE DO
PASSED WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
SANTIAGO NON RESIDENT TUITION
EXEMPTIONS HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE ROBERT
REVISED GOLDEN STATE TEACHER
GRANT PROGRAM TO PASS AS AMENDED
WITH TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY FOUR ROBERT
RIVAS SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEYS
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB SIX SIXTEEN
FORTY FIVE BLANCA RUBIO DREAMER
RESOURCE CENTERS AND LEYVA SIGNS
DO PASSED WITH A B. ROLL CALL.
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY EIGHT CARILLO
ADULT EDUCATION WORK GROUPS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE THREE OF
US LUNCH THE LIBRARY HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
MAIENSCHEIN PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR LITERACY TO PASS
THE ROLL CALL.
AB SEVENTY NO THREE BLOOM
COLLABORATIVE FOR NICK NARROW
DIVERSE CITY LEARNING THAT YOU
SEE DO PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWO KILEY
SCHOOL SAFETY PLANS HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
FIVE CARILLO AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM FUNDING TO PASS IS
AMENDED TO READ MOVE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION AN AMOUNT THAT
GETS OUT AND BE ROLL CALL.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVEN WEBER
CAREER CORSICA MEAN COLLEGE TO
PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE SMITH
SUMMER DORM ROOM INCOMMUNICADO
JUST TO PASS AS AMENDED FORM
WITH EXISTING SUMMER DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROVISIONS PLACE A
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN SUNSET ON
THE CAP PROGRAM.
AND LANGUAGE ENSURING P. E. IS
NOT COUNTED FOR FUNDING CREDIT
THAT COULD HELP WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY MEDINA UC
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN RAMOS PEOPLE SUICIDE
PREVENTION POLICIES TO PASS A
ROLL CALL.
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FOUR BONTA
STUDENT EIGHT APPLICATIONS IN
DISASTER ZONES TO PASS A ROLL
CALL.
ACR SIXTY FOUR MCCARTY SAT AND
ACT STUDY DO PASS.
WITH REPUBLICANS UPLOADING ALL
RIGHT THAT'S EDUCATION.
THE LAST KNOWN TO BE.
I'M GONNA GO BACK TO ACR SIXTY
FOUR MCCARTY SAT AND ACT STUDY --
TO PASS ON A. B. ROLL CALL.
MOVING ON TO MY FAVORITE SUBJECT
LABOR AND HERS.
LOT OF CONSULT AS IN THIS.
ONE ALL RIGHT READY.
THEY ALL PASS AND WE WELCOME
JUST CHECKING.
I'M NOT SURE OF THAT WE'LL GET
BACK.
NOPE NO MORE MOTION MOTION TO
SUPPLEMENT AND IF THAT'S OKAY
ALL RIGHT.
AB FIVE GONZALEZ WORKER
CLASSIFICATION TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL AB NINE REAIS THREE
YEAR COMPLAIN PERIOD YOU PASS ON
IT WITH REPUBLICANS STAINING.
AB THIRTY FIVE KALRA WORKPLACE
REPORTING TO ASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL AB FIFTY ONE CONSULT FOR
SERVER TRACE AND DO PASSED ON TO
BE ROLL CALL.
AB ONE SEVENTY ONE GONZALEZ
RATHMANN RETALIATION DO PASSES
AMENDED TO APPLY TO THE PUBLIC
SECTOR.
IT HAS WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB ONE EIGHTY ONE RODRIGUEZ
EMERGING MANAGERS TO PASS.
ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWO OH THREE FOR MANAGERS.
AB TWO OR THREE SALAS VALLEY
FEVER TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPLY TO ALL WORKERS FOR
AFFECTED EMPLOYERS ON ANY ROLL
CALL.
AB TWO SEVENTY ONE COOPER STATES
SERVICE GENDER PATE REPORT DO
PASS A ROLL CALL AB THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN BONTA RELEASE TIME DO
PASSED THE ROLL CALL.
AB THREE THREE THREE EGGMAN
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO RESTRICT BILL
TO PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES
THAT PASSES WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB THREE SIXTY FIVE C. GARCIA
LEE PROGRAM TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL.
AB THREE SEVENTY TWO VOEPEL
A ROLL CALL.
AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT AMOUNT
CHECK FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
AB FOR THREE KALRA THREE YOUR
COMPLAINT TIME DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REDUCE TIMELINE TO
TWO YEARS THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
AB FIVE TWENTY NINE RAMOS
MANDATORY OVERTIME TO PASS B.
ROLL CALL.
AB FIVE FIVE FIVE GONZALEZ PAID
SICKLY DO PASSED B. ROLL CALL.
SB SIX TWENTY FRANK KALRA WORKER
RETENTION PREFERENCE TO PASS B.
ROLL CALL.
SB. SIX TWENTY EIGHT WANT TO
LEAVE PROTECTION SKI PASSES A
MINUTE TO ADD ADDITIONAL
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS AND
ALLOW EMPLOYERS TO REQUIRE
CERTIFICATION IT'S OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB SIX SEVENTY THREE CARILLO
LATEWAGE PENALTIES TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CPAS SPECIFY A WORKER
CAN ONLY RECEIVE A STATUTORY OR
CIVIL PENALTY BUT NOT BOTH.
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AB SEVEN TWENTY ONE GRAYSON
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
CREEL EQUAL PAY ACT AND GENDER
EXPRESSION HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB EIGHT NINETY FOUR SANTIAGO
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S THAT
POSITIONS TO PASS.
ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AB -- TEN TO RODRIGUEZ.
BARGAINING UNIT SIX MO YOU DO
PASS REPUBLICANS AND STAINING.
AB TEN OH SEVEN JONES SAWYER
ADVERSE ACTION TIMELINE DO PASS
AS AMENDED EXEMPTS CERTAIN CASES
WITHOUT WITH A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION THAT GETS OUT OF
THE ROLL CALL.
AB TEN NINETEEN FRAZIER
APPRENTICESHIP SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
DIVERT DEVELOPMENT LEE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED PERSONS
TO PASS A ROLL CALL. 1-033-
COOPER INFORMATION FOR JOB
APPLICANTS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
MODIFY THE DOCUMENT REQUIREMENTS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB ELEVEN FIFTY CARILLO ELEVATOR
SAFETY AND WORK PERMITS TO PASS
A ROLL CALL.
AB TWELVE TWELVE LEVINE
INFRASTRUCTURE REPORT PROJECT
REPORTING TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
LIMIT AFFECTED AGENCIES OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL.
AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR GRAY PAID
FAMILY LEAVE HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NAZARIAN TURKEY
DIVESTMENT DO PASSED WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE KALRA
GROCERY EMPLOYEE CERTIFICATION
DO PASSED THE ROLL CALL AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT RAMOS
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
CAREER FAIRS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO NEAR THE TYPES OF
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
REMOVE REQUIREMENT RELATED TO
PHYSICAL SPACE.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. SIXTEEN THIRTEEN
O'DONNELL PUBLIC WORKS TO PASS
THE ROLL CALL 1-677- WEBER CALL
CENTERS TO PASS IS MEANT TO
CLARIFY SCOPE OF STATE BENEFIT
DISALLOWANCE OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL.
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE AND SALAS
SCHOOL PEACE OFFICER BARGAINING
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE AT
LEAST TWO SUPERVISORY PEACE
OFFICERS TO FORM. EIGHT
BARGAINING UNIT OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL.
THAT IS LABOR
.
NEXT WE'RE GONNA DO RESOURCES.
RESOURCES AND UTILITIES.
WE READY -- ALL RIGHT.
AB TWENTY ONE OBERNOLTE DRIVER'S
LICENSE FEE WAIVER HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB FORTY FOUR FRIEDMAN
BAN ON FOR PRODUCTS TO PASS ON A
B. ROLL CALL.
AB FORTY SEVEN DAILY DRIVING
VIOLATION POINTS FOR DISTRACTED
DRIVING.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO SPECIFY A
VIOLATION POINT SHALL BE GIVEN
ONLY FIRST SECOND OR ADDITIONAL
CONVICTION OCCURRING WITHIN
THIRTY SIX MONTHS OF A PRIOR
VIOLATION.
THAT PASSES WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB FIFTY SIX HE GARCIA
ELECTRICITY PROCUREMENT DO PASS.
ON A. B. ROLL CALL.
AB SIXTY FRIEDMAN WATER METER
ACCURACY STANDARDS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
AB ONE TWENTY SIX COOPER CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATES DO PASS A ROLL
CALL.
AB ONE THIRTY FOUR BLOOM SAFE
DRINKING WATER TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELETE THE COMPLIANCE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM REFRAME
ARTICLE FOR AS LEGISLATIVE
INTENT AND ADD LEAD AND COPPER
TO THE PROBLEMS TO BE ADDRESSED.
MAKE OTHER QUITE CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO LINE TO AB ONE THIRTY
FOUR IN AB.
TWO SEVENTEEN THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS OF SEEING.
AB ONE FORTY TWO CRISTINA GARCIA
BATTERY FEE TO PASS WITH AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO DELAY REPORT
REQUIREMENT FOR ONE YEAR AND
MAKE TECHNICAL CLARIFICATIONS B.
ROLL CALL.
AB ONE FORTY FOUR AGUIAR-CURRY
ORGANIC WASTE HOLDING COMMITTEE
AB ONE FIFTY EIGHT VOEPEL
PARKING AT ROADSIDE REST AREAS
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB ONE SIXTY ONE TEEN PAPER
RECEIPTS.
DO YOU PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS
EXEMPT FROM THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THIS BILL.
BUSINESSES THAT USE B. P. A. B.
PS FREE PAPER AND ONLY PUT
TRANSITION TRANSACTION
INFORMATION ON THE RECEIPT THAT
GETS OUT WITH A B. ROLL CALL.
AB ONE EIGHTY THREE WOULD TELL
COME NATURAL DISASTER REPORTS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
AB TWO OH NINE LIMON
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION GRANT
PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB TWO SEVENTEEN EDUARDO GARCIA
SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR ALL ACT
DO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO DELETED DRESS FINE INCREASE
AXES TO A TOTAL OF THIRTY
MILLION ANNUALLY AUTHORIZED
FUNDING FOR THE AG TO RECOVER
CLEANUP COSTS FROM POLLUTERS
ALLOW FUNDING TO ADDRESS LEAD
AND COPPER CONTAMINATION PROVIDE
AND ANY UNUSED MONEY ALLOCATED
TO REGIONS. TO REVERT TO THE
FIND AT AN URGENCY CLAUSE MAKE
OTHER CLERK CLARIFYING AMENDMENT
SECONDS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL.
AB TWO THIRTY FIVE MAYES
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES COST
EXPENSIVE STUDENTS TO PASS A
ROLL CALL.
AB TWO FIFTY TWO DALY DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION ER PROCESS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN MATHIS BIO
MASS COLLECTION AND CONVERSION
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB TWO SIX
NINE QUIRK SILVA WAIVER OF
DRIVING TEST FOR LICENSED
DRIVERS FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
AB TWO SEVENTY FOUR MATHIS
TWENTY MILLION APPROPRIATION
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT MCCARTY
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB TWO EIGHTY FOUR FRAZIER
JUNIOR HUNTING LICENSE SENSE AT
EXTENSION HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWO EIGHTY FIVE FRIEDMAN
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION PLAN
TO PASS [inaudible]
ROLL CALL.
AB TWO NINETY SIX COOLEY CLIMATE
CHANGE TAX.
CLIMATE CHANGE TAX CHECK OFF IN
GRANTS TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB THREE THIRTEEN FRAZIER UC AND
CSU REPORTS ON RESEARCH FUNDED
BY TRANSPORTATION MONIES TO PASS
A ROLL CALL AB THREE SEVENTEEN
DEAR.
UNLAWFUL SALE DMV APPOINTMENTS
TO PASS AS AMENDED DOES NOT
SPECIFY A VIOLATION IS A
MISDEMEANOR A ROLL CALL.
AB THREE TWENTY QUIRK MOSQUITO
ABATEMENT DO PASSES AMENDED TO
MAKE THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BILL CONTINGENT UPON THE RECEIPT
OF FEDERAL OR STATE GRANTS OR
PRIVATE DONATIONS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL.
ABTHREE THIRTY SIX MATHIS FREE
PART FOR KIDS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB THREE FORTY TWO MURATSUCHI
OIL AND NATURAL GAS LEASES ON
STATE LANDS. TO PASS AB THREE
FORTY THREE PATTERSON BIO MASS
TRANSPORTATION GRANTS.
I'M SORRY TO PASS I'M SURE ON A
B. ROLL CALL.
YEAH AB.
THREE FORTY TWO YEAH.
THANK YOU FOR CATCHING THAT.
AB THREE FORTY THREE PM
PATTERSON BIO MASS
TRANSPORTATION GROUNDS HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
AB THREE FIFTY TWO EACH GARCIA
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO LIMITEXPANSION G.
G. R. F. FUNDS AND FOCUS GRANT
RESTRICTIONS ON THE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB THREE EIGHTY FRAZIER OFFICE
OF THE TRANSPORTATION INSPECTOR
GENERAL HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
THREE EIGHTY TWO MATHIS UPPER
WATERSHED GRANTS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
AB THREE EIGHTY THREE MAYES
CLEAN ENERGY FINANCING CLEARING
HOUSE HOLDING COMMITTEE AB THREE
EIGHTY SIX EDUARDO GARCIA AB
WORKING POOR ENERGY EFFICIENT
HOUSING PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL
CALL.
IT BEFORE TO QUIRK SMALL
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS DO PASSED
WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING AB
FOUR NINE LIMON CLIMATE CHANGE
GRANTS FOR AGRICULTURE TO PASS A
ROLL CALL.
AB FOR TWENTY THREE GLORIA SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT TWO PASSES
AMENDED TO MODIFY PROVISIONS
RELATING TO THE MILITARY THE
ROLL CALL.
AB FOR THIRTY TWO QUIRK
CERTIFICATION LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
FOR FORTY ONE EGGMAN UNDERGROUND
WATER STORAGE HOLDING COMMITTEE
AB FOR FORTY EIGHT GARCIA
STOPPED KHAN TOLD IN COMMITTEE.
AB FOR FORTY NINE GALLAGHER
FEATHER RIVER CROSSING TO PASS A
ROLL CALL A BILL AB FOR FIFTY
FOUR KALRA MIGRATORY BIRDS TO
PASS WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
LINE THE BILL WITH FEDERAL LAW
AS IT EXISTED JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY SEVENTEEN B. ROLL CALL.
AB FOR SEVENTY LOW MOAN
CALIFORNIA GREEN BUSINESS
PROGRAM HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
FORTY NINE MARK STONE FLOOD
CONTROL PROJECTS TO PASS A ROLL
CALL.
AB FOR NINETY ONE BLANCA RUBIO
HYDROGEN STUDY HOLDING COMMUNITY
AB FOR NINETY SEVEN SANTIAGO
DEAF AND DISABLED COMMUNICATIONS
TO PASS REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB FIVE OH EIGHT TWO THAT SAID
KANSEN CHU PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION DO PASSED B. ROLL
CALL AB FIVE FIFTY TWO MARK
STONE CAUSAL ADAPTATION REASON
LANCE RESILIENCE. TO PASS B.
ROLL CALL.
AB FIVE FIFTY SIX CREE OAK MANY
OUTDOOR ACCESS GRANTS DO PASSED
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB FIVE FIFTY SEVEN WOULD
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB SIX SIXTEEN
PATTERSON FORCE CARBON PLAN
REPORTS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB SIX THREE SEVEN GREAT
DRINKING WATER HOLDEN COMMITTEE
AB SIX THIRTY GREAT CLIMATE
IMPACTS ON WATER SUPPLY DO
PASSES A MINUTE TO LINE
REQUIREMENTS WITH EXISTING
REPORTS AND LESSEN THE FREQUENCY
OF THE REPORTS A ROLL CALL.
AB SIX THIRTY NINE CERVANTES
LOWER CARBON SEE PARTS TO PASS A
ROLL CALL.
AB SIX FIFTY EIGHT EDUARDO
GARCIA GRAHAM WHAT'S WATER
STORAGE DO PASSED WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING AB SIX
FIFTY NINE MULLIN CALIFORNIA'S
MARZI COLLEGE GRANT PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB SIX SIXTY ONE MCCARTY
SACRAMENTO METRO A Q.M. D. DO
PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB SEVEN OH EIGHT FRAZIER
TRAFFIC VIOLATORS SCHOOLS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL AB SEVEN TWENTY
TWO BIGELOW SMALL DAM FEE
REDUCTION TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
733- QUIRK HAZARDOUS WASTE
TESTING DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THE
REQUIREMENT OF THE BILL
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATIONS
REQUIRED DTS SEED TO COMPLETE
THE ALTERNATIVE TEST WITHIN FIVE
YEARS AND REQUIRE ANY UNSPENT
FUNDS TO REVERT.
A ROLL CALL AB SEVEN FORTY BURKE
CLIMATE CHANGE CATASTROPHE
COMPENSATION FUND DO PASSES
AMENDED TO FOCUS ON VICTIMS OF
FIRES NATURAL DISASTERS.
THAT PASSES WITH REPUBLICANS OF
STAINING. SEVEN FIFTY TWO
GABRIEL LACTATION ROOMS IN
TRANSIT STATIONS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPLY ONLY TO
TRANSPORTATION STATIONS OF NO
LESS THAN FOUR THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET AND ONE THAT INCLUDES A
PUBLIC RESTROOM.
EIGHT ROLL CALL.
AB SEVEN FIFTY THREE EDUARDO
GARCIA ALTERNATE FUELS VEHICLES
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO DELETE THE
PROVISION RELATING TO THE
PROGRAM AT THE A. R. B..
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
OF STAINING.
AB SEVEN FIFTY FIVE HOLDEN
CALIFORNIA TIRE FEE STORMWATER
PERMIT COMPLIANCE TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO REQUIRE THE C. D.
T. F. EIGHT TO COLLECT THE FEE.
ALLOW ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND
EXPAND THE GRANT PROGRAM TO
COVER ALL STORM WATER POLLUTANTS
THE ROLL CALL.
AB SEVENTY EIGHTY THREE BIGELOW
AMERICAN RIVER PARKWAY TO PASS A
ROLL CALL AB SEVEN NINETY TWO
TEEN PLASTIC BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
TO PASS WITH A MINISTRY MAY WITH
A 100% BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
GOAL B. ROLL CALL.
AB SEVEN NINETY FOURTEEN
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
REPORT HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
AB EIGHT OH ONE LEVINE SOLAR
TEAR SOME PROGRAM STUDY HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR
QUIRK H. A. B. WATER QUALITY DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE THE
WATER BOARD TO ESTABLISH MINIMUM
HEALTH STANDARDS FOR WATER
BODIES.
I COULD TELL WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB EIGHT THIRTY FIVE QUIRK SAFE
RECREATIONAL WATER USE HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
AB EIGHT THIRTY SIX WEEKS CLEAN
AIR CENTERS DO PASS AS AMENDED
PRIOR TO HIGH SCHOOLS AND
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES A ROLL CALL.
AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE MULLIN
CLIMATE ADAPTATION TO PASS THE
ROLL CALL.
AB EIGHT FORTY ONE TEEN DRINKING
WATER CONTAMINANTS TO PASS.
A ROLL CALL.
AB EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT BIGELOW
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS DE
ENERGIZING PLANNING HOLDING
COMMUNITY.
AB EIGHT EIGHTY THREE DOLLY DFW
WILDFIRE REPORTS HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
AB NINE ELEVEN RODRIGUEZ -- YES
EMERGENCY INFORMATION SYSTEM DO
PASS AS AMENDED REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT -- FOR YES TO
IMPLEMENT THE PLAN A ROLL CALL
892-6 O'DONNELL OIL TRUST FUND
TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB NINE THIRTY THREE
PETRIE-NORRIS WATERSHED
COORDINATORS TO PASS WITH
AUTHORS MOMENTS TO ADD FEDERALLY
NON FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES
IS ELIGIBLE GRANT RECIPIENTS
PROVIDED AP A EXEMPTION TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT COULD
HELP WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB NINE THIRTY SIX ROBERT RIVAS
OIL SPILL RESPONSE PLANNING TO
PASS WITH AUTHOR MEMBERS STREAM
OF THE REQUIREMENT FOR
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL CAPABILITY
INSURANCE B. ROLL CALL.
AB NINE FIFTY FIVE GIPSON WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT YOU PASS
WITH A MOMENT TO ADD A SANTA
CLAUS A ROLL CALL.
AB NINE SIXTY ONE RIVAS ENERGY
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS NOT ENERGY
BENEFITS HOLDEN COMMITTEE EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTY SALAS DEPARTMENT
AGING TRANSPORTATION GRANTS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. 898-0 KALRA
DMV ENHANCE CONFIDENTIAL
CONFIDENTIALITY HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
AB TEN TWENTY FIVE GRAYSON SAN
RAMON BRANCH COURT OR
REIMBURSEMENT TO PASS A ROLL
CALL.
AB TEN TWENTY EIGHT AND SALAS
CLEAN ENERGY JOB CREATION
PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB TEN FORTY SIXTEEN CHARGER HAD
CALIFORNIA NISH TO BE PASSED THE
ROLL CALL.
AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN LIMON OIL AND
GAS AND DAN INDEMNITY BONDS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REMOVE THE
PROVISION THAT DOUBLES THE
AMOUNT FOR BLANKET INDEMNITY
BONDS B. ROLL CALL.
AB TEN SIXTY SEVEN BIGELOW DPR
WILDFIRE MANAGEMENT PLANS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
AB TEN EIGHTY GONZALEZ
CALIFORNIA CIRCULAR ECONOMY IN
PLASTIC POLLUTION REDUCTION ACT
TO PASS THE ROLL CALL.
AB TEN EIGHTY SIX BARRICADE HAN
SWEET PROGRAM TO PASS THE ROLL
CALL.
NOW IT'S OKAY AB TEN NINETY
THREE BLANCA RUBIO MUNICIPAL
STORM UPSET.
STORM SYSTEM -- ME TRY THIS
AGAIN.
AB TEN NINETY THREE BLANCA RUBIO
MUNICIPAL STORM SEWER SYSTEMS TO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO ADD
LEGISLATIVE FINANCING REQUIRE
THE STATE REGIONAL BOARDS
CONTINUE WORKING WITH PERMIT
HOLDERS.
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB ELEVEN ELEVEN FRIEDMAN
OFFICER OUTDOOR RECREATION DO
PASS FOR THE MEMBERS TO PLACE
OFFICE IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
A ROLL CALL.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY FOUR LOW MOAN
TRAFFIC TICKET INSTALLMENT PLANS
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB ELEVEN FIFTY SIX EDUARDO
GARCIA ENVIRONMENTAL CREDIT
INSURANCE PILOT PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO KALRA
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS AND
LODGING ESTABLISHMENTS. TO PASS
AS AMENDED REDUCE THE SIZE A
PROHIBITED BOTTLES TO THREE
OUNCES A BLOW AND ALLOW THE
LODGING ESTABLISHMENTS BRIGHT
FREE PLASTIC BOTTLES OF SHAMPOO
HAIR CONDITIONER BATH SOAP IN
PLACE OF OTHER THAN THE ROOM
UPON REQUEST GETS OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL.
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FRIEDMAN
RECYCLED WATER TO PASS.
A ROLL CALL AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
BONTA OAKLAND WATERFRONT
BALLPARK ACT TO DO PASS A ROLL
CALL GO ETS.
AB TWELVE THIRTY TWO GLORIA
WEATHER'S ASIAN FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO PASS THE ROLL CALL.
AB TWELVE THIRTY SIX LACKEY
RECYCLING HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWELVE FIFTY FOUR
KAMLAGER-DOVE BOBCATS TO PASS B.
ROLL CALL AB TWELVE SIXTY
MAIENSCHEIN ENDANGERED WILDLIFE
TO PASS.
THE ROLL CALL. 1-267- ROBERT
RIVAS PROVISIONALDRIVER'S
LICENSES EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY YEAR
OLDS HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB TWELVE
NINETY THREE LEVINE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION REPORT ON
RATES HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTEEN HUNDRED CALL MONGER
JOBS FOR THE CAUSE PROGRAM
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB THIRTEEN TEN
RADIUS TRAFFIC VIOLATORS SCHOOL
FEES TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE JONES
SORRY COMMUNITY SERVICE FOR
PARKING TICKETS HOLDEN COMMITTEE
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT HOLDEN
OIL AND GAS TO PASS B. ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE LACKEY
TRANSIT OPERATORS PARA TRANSIT
DIAL A RIDE SERVICES ASSESSMENT
DO PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO O'DONNELL
INTERESTED UTILITY RATE PROGRAM
INFORMATION DO PASSES AMENDED
REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT AT C. P.
YOU SEE ENSURE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO INFORMATION
OUTSIDE THE C. P. UC'S
JURISDICTION.
THAT IS HOW THE REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX GONZALEZ
VOICE OVER INTERNET PROTOCOL AND
INTERNET PROTOCOL ENABLE
COMMUNICATION SERVICES DO PASS
AS AMENDED. TO CREATE A SEVENTY
TWO HOUR STANDARD FOR
RESTORATION OF RESIDENTIAL
INTERCONNECTED VOICE SERVICES
PROVIDE A BILL CREDIT FOR
REQUESTED BY THE CUSTOMER OF THE
RESIDENTIAL INTERCONNECT WHAT
SERVICES IS OUT FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
REQUIRE THE PROVIDER TO DISCLOSE
CERTAIN INFORMATION TO A
POTENTIAL WHITE CUSTOMER.
REQUIRE THE CPUC TO REPORT VOID
CUSTOMER COMPLAINTS TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AS WELL AS THE
LEGISLATURE MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING CHANGES THAT GETS OUT
WITH THE REPUBLICANS OF STAINING.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD
TWELVE MONTHS CONSECUTIVE
FISHING LICENSE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELETE THE CONTENTS
OF THE BILL AND INSTEAD CREATED
TWELVE MONTHS CONSECUTIVE
LICENSE AT A 130%.
THE COST OF A REGULAR LICENSE
PROVIDE THE OPTION FOR AUTOMATIC
RENEWAL ALLOW DFW TO RECOVER
COSTS REQUIRED DFW TO COLLECT
DATA REPORT TO LEGISLATURE IN
ADDISON TO CLOCK.
THAT GETS OUT.
WITH THE REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB FORTINO ONE FONG SURCHARGES
ON PARKING VIOLATIONS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB FORTINO NINE CHAO
HOMEWORK OUT PROJECTS HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN FRIEDMAN
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS CIVIL
PENALTIES DO PASSED THE ROLL
CALL.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR BERMAN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS OPEN ACCESS TO PASS A
ROLL CALL AB FOURTEEN FORTY
LIVING IN OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT TO PASS B. ROLL CALL.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY TWO SANTIAGO
EXCITE CLEAN UP HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BURKE PLASTIC BEVERAGE
REPORTING.
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED CARILLO HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES DO PASSED REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING AB FIFTY NO THREE
BURKE DISTRIBUTIVE ENERGY AND
MICRO GETS WORKFORCE REPORT
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB FIFTY NO NINE MULLIN BATTERY
RECYCLING TO PASS REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN BLOOM SANTA
MONICA BAY RESTORATION
COMMISSION TO PASS A ROLL CALL
AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN FRIEDMAN FIRE
PREVENTION DO PASS A ROLL CALL.
1-540-9 O'DONNELL SANTA CATALINA
ISLAND HOLDEN COMMITTEE FIFTEEN
EIGHTY THREE EGGMAN THIS
CALIFORNIA RECYCLING MARKET
DEVELOPMENT OUT TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELETE THE NEW GRANT
PROGRAM.
THAT PASSES WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
GLORIA WATER WASTEWATER
CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS FOR
VETERANS TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
1-589- SALAS CHROME WHERE AIR
QUALITY PROGRAM HOLDEN COMMITTEE
FIFTEEN NINETY SIX QUIRK
CONTAMINATE PROPERTY CLEAN UP TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. 1-614- GIPSON
EXTENSION ALTERNATIVE LICENSE
PLATE PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL
CALL 1-657- EDUARDO GARCIA
OFFICE OF THE SONG SEED TO PASS
A ROLL CALL. 1-668- CARILLO CCC
RE ENTRY PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. 1-671- BERMAN DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION MOTOR VEHICLE
TECH.
KNOWLEDGE HE TESTING DO PASS A
ROLL CALL 1-680- LOW MOAN
HOLLISTER RANCH TO PASS
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY FOUR O'DONNELL
SAN GABRIEL LOWER LOS ANGELES
RIVERS MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY DO
PASS REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN LEVINE KNOWS
MAKE NO SMOKING AND STATE PARKS
AND BEACHES DO PASSED THE ROLL
CALL 1-751- AND DAVID CHIU
CONSOLIDATION WATER AND SEWER
CORPORATIONS TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
1-770- FRAZIER TIRE RECYCLING
PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB SEVENTY NINETY NINE FRIEDMAN
NATURAL GAS MARKET OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE HOLDING COMMITTEE
.
ALL RIGHT.
ARE WE READY
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
AB.
THREE I'M SORRY THIS HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES -- PACKET.
AB THREE COOPER ADOLESCENT
CANNABIS PREVENTION FIND HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
AB FOR BONTA XP ANY MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY TO LOW INCOME ADULTS
TO PASS AS AMENDED IT COULD MAKE
CONTINGENT ON A BUDGET
PREPARATION FOR THE PURPOSES AND
MAKE MINOR CLARIFYING CHANGES.
BE ROLL CALL. FORTY THREE GLORIA
MENTAL HEALTH DATA TRANSPARENCY
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO REDUCE THE
SCOPE OF AN AUTHORITY FOR DATA
ACCESS FROM OTHER GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES A ROLL CALL.
AB FIFTY KALRA MEDI CAL ASSISTED
LIVING WAIVER TO PASS A ROLL
CALL ONE TWENTY FIVE MCCARTY
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE REFORM TO
PASS AS AMENDED WITH TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS A ROLL CALL. ONE
SIXTY THREE CRISTINA GARCIA
FACILITIES LAST ON FOR
UNACCOMPANIED UNDOCUMENTED
MINORS DO PASS REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. ONE SIXTY SIX
GABRIEL MEDI CAL VIOLENCE
PREVENTION SERVICE TO PASS
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING ONE SIXTY
SEVEN BLANCA RUBIO STATE FUNDING
FOR INFANT TODDLER CHILD CARE
SERVICES HOLDEN COMMITTEE. ONE
SEVENTY FOUR WOULD HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE AFFORDABILITY
ASSISTANCE TO PASS AS AMENDED
MAKE IMPLEMENTATION CONTINGENT
ON TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET APPROPRIATION OPERATES
COLOR COVER CALIFORNIA TO REDUCE
SUBSIDIES BASED ON APPROPRIATION
LEVEL.
MAKES SENSE CITY PAYMENTS
CONTINGENT ON AVAILABILITY OF
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES SPECIFY THE
LEVEL PREMIUM ASSISTANCE IS
BASED UPON THE PRICE OF THE
SECOND LOWEST COSTS OVER PLAN.
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
ONE SEVENTY FIVE GIPSON FOSTER
YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS TO PASS.
THE ROLL CALL. ONE NINETY TWO
MATHIS CALIFORNIANS GREAT
COMMUNITY LIVING PROGRAM HOLDEN
COMMITTEE ONE NINETY FOUR
VARIOUS STATE FUNDS FOR CHILD
CARE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
HOLDING COMMUNITY.
SHOW FOR WHAT HOSPITAL COMMUNITY
BENEFITS REPORTING TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE REQUIREMENTS
FOR INDEPENDENT AUDITS REPORTS
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES IN TO
FIND AN EXEMPTION AND OTHER
MINOR CHANGES.
REPUBLICANS OF STAINING. TO
FOURTEEN MULLIN SPINAL CORD
INJURY RESEARCH PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE TO TWENTY EIGHT
AGUIAR-CURRY INDUSTRIAL HEMP TO
PASS A ROLL CALL 229- IS THERE
AN AYE HSS WRITTEN CONTENT.
TRANSLATION HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWO THIRTY TWO CERVANTES REPORT
IN VETERAN SUICIDE DO PASSES A
MINUTE TO TO PROVIDE THE
REQUIRED TO REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS A ROLL CALL. TO
CITY ONE MATHIS REGIONAL AND
CAN'T CENTER IN CAMPING
RECREATION SERVICES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE TO EIGHTY THREE KANSEN
CHU REPEAL CAL WORKS
IMMUNIZATION SCHOOL ATTENDANCE
REQUIREMENTS.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO REINSTATE
THE IMMUNIZATION REQUIREMENTS A
MORE FLEXIBLE SANCTION AND
INFORMATION PIECES FOR
IMMUNIZATIONS AND TWENTY
ASSISTANCE AB REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. TWO NINETY WORD
THIRD PARTY PAYMENTS OF HEALTH
CARE PREMIUMS DO PASSES AMENDED
TO FURTHER SPECIFY THE TERM
FINANCIALLY INTERESTED AS IT
RELATES TO DIALYSIS CLINICS BE
ROLL CALL. 307- RACE HOMELESS
YOUTH GRANT PROGRAM TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE APPROPRIATION
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES A ROLL
CALL. 311- FRAZIER REGIONAL
CENTER DALY BILLING RATES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE THREE SIXTEEN RAMIS
MEDI CAL SPECIAL DENTAL RATE.
DENTAL CARE NEEDS SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT HOLDEN COMMITTEE THREE
EIGHTEEN KANSEN CHU READABILITY
TRANSLATE MATERIALS A MEDI CAL
DO PASSES AMENDED TO NEAR THE
DOCUMENTS IT MUST BE FIELD
TESTED B. ROLL CALL. 319- BLANCA
RUBIO EXPANSION OF DRUG MEDI CAL
BENEFITS HOLDEN COMMITTEE THREE
TWENTY FOUR AGUIAR-CURRY.
STATE SUBSIDIZED HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONAL SUPPORT STIPENDS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ADD INTENT
LANGUAGE MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING. THREE
THIRTY SEVEN QUIRK SILVA FOSTER
CARE PROVIDER REASONABLE TRAVEL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SCHOOL DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO ALLOW SOCIAL
WORKERS ADDITIONAL NOTIFICATION
TIME A ROLL CALL. 340-1
MAIENSCHEIN CAL HERE'S
APPLICATION FOR CALIFORNIA HELD
IN COMMITTEE THREE EIGHTY FIVE
CALDERON SHARED FUNCTIONAL
ASSESSMENT DATA SYSTEM A MEDIC
CAL HOLDING COMMITTEE. THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN GABRIEL PRINTING
THE PURPOSE OF A DRUG ON THE
PRESCRIPTION BOTTLE DO PASSES
AMENDED TO INSTEAD REQUIRE
DISCUSSION B. ROLL CALL. 388-
THE MON ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE DO
PASSES AMENDED TO STRIKE THE
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN TO
SPECIFIED APARTMENTS ACTIVITY
SHOULD BE CONDUCTED. TO THE
EXTENT RESOURCES REMOVED
AVAILABLE INTO ADDED TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE CENTS AT A ROLL CALL.
AB FOR FOURTEEN BONTA SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY PAYMENT FOR
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO PHASE OUT IF THE
FEDERAL PENALTIES REINSTATED.
AB FOR TWENTY SAID SIX DID THAT
MAKE SENSE.
NO I'M SORRY THE ROLL CALL YEAH
SORRY.
OF COURSE PEOPLE.
AB FOR TWENTY SIX MAIENSCHEIN I
HSS MEDICAL CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO STRIKE THE AUTHORIZATION
AUTHORIZED HOURS LANGUAGE A ROLL
CALL.
AB FOR THIRTY EIGHT FRAZIER
REGIONAL CENTER UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB FOR
EIGHTY SALAS.
OLDER ADULT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ADMINISTRATOR TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. 512- TEEN CULTURAL
COMPETENCY IN DISPARITIES MEDI
CAL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO MODIFY THE
REQUIREMENT COMPLIANCE WITH
TARGET LEVELS.
PACKAGE HOW WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING FIVE FIFTEEN MATHIS
MEDI CAL INTEREST RATE FOR OVER
PAYMENTS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
START THE CHANGE TO INTEREST
RATES.
BACK AT THAT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB FIVE TWENTY SIX PETRIE-NORRIS
WE CAN ROAMING GATEWAY FOR MEDI
CAL DO PASSES AMENDED REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT TO COMPLETE A
PROJECT.
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE PRIOR TO
IMPLEMENTING THE PROJECT INTO
STRIKE THING MAY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY DEADLINE THAT COULD TELL
WITH REPUBLICANS IT STAINING.
AB FIVE THIRTY ONE FRIEDMAN
HOUSING OPTION FOR A FOSTER
YOUTH AN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE TO
PASS AS AMENDED WITH TECHNICAL
MEMONS A ROLL CALL. 534- MAYES
ACCESS TO FOOD PLAN HOLDING
COMMITTEE. FIVE THIRTY SIX
FRAZIER DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICE
ELIGIBILITY AGE INCREASE HOLDEN
COMMITTEE FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
WOULD QUALITY IMPROVEMENT MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. FIVE SIXTY THREE
QUIRK SILVA GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION FOR ORANGE COUNTY
TASK FORCE HOLDING COMMITTEE.
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT REYES
CALIFORNIA CARE CORP BACKED
HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
BY SEVENTY SEVEN EGGMAN MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY BASED ON MEANT
MATERNAL MOUNT MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
STRIKE THE CONTENTS OF THIS BILL
INSTEAD.
REQUIRE TRANSITION ASSISTANCE TO
COVER CALIFORNIA PLAN FOR ALL
ELIGIBLE WOMEN JUST ROLLING FOR
MEDI CAL AND SIXTY DAYS.
POST PARTUM INSURE PROVIDER
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR WOMEN
WITH MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS XML CAL FOR A YEAR
ONLY FOR ANY POST PARTUM WOMEN.
WOMEN UNDER 110038% OF F. P. L.
NOT OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE FOR
PUBLIC COVERAGE THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT BLOOM
INSURANCE COVERAGE OF HEARING
AIDS FOR CHILDREN DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO LIMIT THE COVERAGE TO
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
HEARING AID.
A ROLL CALL AB SIX SEVENTEEN
MULLIN STEM CELL AND
REGENERATIVE. TO HAVE THEIR P.
REGULATION ADVISORY GROUP HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. FIVE I'M SORRY A. B.
SIX TWENTY SEVEN FRAZIER
REGIONAL CENTERS SATELLITE
OFFICES DO PASSES MEDITECH STAND
THE BILL MAKES IMPLEMENTATION
DAY BY SIX MONTHS A ROLL CALL.
640-1 FRAZIER REGIONAL CENTER
INTEGRATE COMPETITIVE EMPLOYMENT
HOLDEN COMMITTEE SIX FIFTY LOW
VIOLENT DEATH DATA COLLECTION
HOLDEN COMMITTEE SIX FIFTY ONE
GRAYSON AIR AMBULANCE SERVICES
DO PASS THE ROLL CALL 656-
EDUARDO GARCIA OFFICE OF HEALTHY
AND SAFE COMMUNITIES DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE
APPROPRIATION B. ROLL CALL. 678-
FLOOR MEDI CAL PODIATRY SERVICES
TO PASS A ROLL CALL 682- EGGMAN
GRANT APPLICATION FOR MENTAL
HEALTH BEDS SYSTEMS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. SIX EIGHTY FIVE RAMOS.
LEGAL SERVICES FOR INDIAN TRIBE
CHILD WELFARE MATTERS TO PASS A
ROLL CALL 704- PATTERSON DUTCH
DRUG TREATMENT FACILITIES
BACKGROUND CHECKS HOLDING
COMMITTEE SEVEN THIRTEEN MULLIN
EARLY PSYCHOSIS INTERVENTION
PLUS PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
715- WHAT MEDI CAL AGING
DISABLED ELIGIBILITY PROGRAM TO
PASS SEVEN EIGHTEEN I WILL NOT A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU. SEVEN
EIGHTEEN EGGMAN DOCUMENTS FOR
YOUTH AGING OUT OF FOSTER CARE
DO PASSES MANAGES SPECIFIED
EDUCATIONAL DOCUMENTS MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES A ROLL CALL.
719- DEEP MEDI CAL AB NINETY
SEVEN RATE REDUCTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE BILL
CONTENT SINCE IN INSTEAD EXPRESS
LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO REVERSE
REDUCTIONS A ROLL CALL.
AB SEVEN THIRTY ONE KALRA RATE
REVIEW IN LARGE GROUP MARKETS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO NARROW THE
REVIEW PROCESS TO INSTEAD REVIEW
RATE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS SEES.
ALLOW INDIVIDUAL RATE CHANGES TO
BE REVIEWED UPON REQUEST ANOTHER
CHANGES BE ROLL CALL. 734-
MAIENSCHEIN SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PILOT PROGRAM FOR RESOURCE
FAMILIES DO PASS AS AMENDED
SCALE BACK TO SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES REQUIREMENTS A ROLL
CALL. 740-1 KALRA TRAUMA
SCREENING HOLDEN COMMITTEE SEVEN
FORTY FOUR AGUIAR-CURRY TELL
HEALTH COVERAGE TO PASS AS
AMENDED A CLEAR FIND AMENDMENT
TO DREAM OF THE REQUIRED
COMPLIANCE REVIEW A ROLL CALL.
SOME FORTY GIPSON EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE ELIGIBILITY DO
PASSES MEANT TO MAKE CLEAR FIND
TECHNICAL CHANGES A ROLL CALL.
763- GREAT STANDARD FORMS FOR
MEDI CAL SPECIAL T. MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES DO PASSES
AMENDED PLAY ONLY TO MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS AND TO ADD A
STAKEHOLDER TO THE WORKERS.
SEVEN A ROLL CALL SORRY SEVEN
SIXTY FOUR BONTA SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES DISTRIBUTION
INCENTIVES TO PASS AS AMENDED
EXEMPT ADDITIONAL BEVERAGES FROM
THE DEFINITION OF SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES B. ROLL CALL.
767- WICKS COVERAGE OF
INFERTILITY TREATMENT.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE THE
COVERAGE REQUIREMENT INSTEAD
REQUIRE CONSIDERATION OF
INCLUDING INFERTILITY TREATMENTS
WHEN ESSENTIAL BENEFIT HEALTH
BENEFIT PLANS ARE REASSESSED.
I GET THAT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. SEVEN SIXTY NINE
SMITH ADDING LPC SEES AS CLAIM
PROVIDERS AND MEDI CAL DO PASS A
ROLL CALL. 770- EDUARDO GARCIA
COMMUNITY CLINIC REIMBURSEMENT
RATES HOLDING COMMITTEE. SEVEN
EIGHTY BRO HEARING AID
DISPENSERS SCOPE OF PRACTICE
HOLDING COMMITTEE SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT CERVANTES MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH PILOT DO PASS A ROLL CALL.
807- OUR QUE HAN ACCEPTED
SCHOLARSHIPS SHIPS FROM INCOME
FOR CAL WORKS ELIGIBILITY
PURPOSES DO PASSES AMENDED TO
STRIKE THE BANK ACCOUNT LANGUAGE
AN EXEMPT INCOME EARNED FROM
CENSUS WORK AND TO ADD AN
EMERGENCY CLAUSE A ROLL CALL.
810- GIPSON ORGAN AND TISSUE
TRANSPLANT WORKING GROUP HOLDING
COMMITTEE EIGHT TWELVE FRAZIER
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES OR SITE
ACCOUNTABILITY HOLDING COMMITTEE
EIGHT THIRTEEN FRAZIER REGIONAL
CENTER ALTERNATE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION RESOLUTION HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
WOULD PAY TO DELAYED CREATE FOR
DELAYED PHARMACEUTICAL
AGREEMENTS.
DO PASSED TO CHANGES STANDARD
PROVED TO SHOWN AGREEMENT IS NOT
ANTI COMPETITIVE FROM CLEAR AND
CONVINCING TO POP PREPONDERANCE
OF THE EVIDENCE REPUBLICANS OF
STAINING. EIGHT TWENTY SIX REYES
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFERRED TO PASS
A ROLL CALL 840-8 GRADE MEDI CAL
COVERAGE OF CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE
MONITORS TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
865- REYES RESOURCE FAMILIES
HUMAN TRAFFICKING TRAINING TO
PASS AS AMENDED MODIFIED ONGOING
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS A ROLL
CALL. 887- CALL REMOVING OFFICE
OF HEALTH EQUITY CERTAIN
GENERAL'S OFFICE HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
WHERE X. CHILDREN'S BEHAVIOR
HEALTH ACTION TEAM TO PASS A
ROLL CALL 914- HOLDEN SUSPENDING
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY FOR INMATES
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO APPLY ONLY
TO INDIVIDUALS UNDER TWENTY SIX
YEARS OF AGE A ROLL CALL. 919-
PETRIE-NORRIS ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM FOR UNLAWFUL DRUG
TREATMENT REFERRALS TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. 940-2 WEBER CALPERS
RESTAURANT MEALS PROGRAM DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO EXTEND THE
IMPLEMENTATION DAY BY SIX MONTHS
A ROLL CALL. 960- MAIENSCHEIN
CAL WORKS HOMELESS ASSISTANCE TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE THE
GROSS INCOME PROVISIONS TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES.
I SKIPPED A PAGE [inaudible]
OKAY. NINE FORTY FOUR WILL GET
BACK TO MAIENSCHEIN THAT WAS A
TO PASS SOME. NINE FORTY FOUR
QUIRK CAL WORKS INDIGENTS
EXCEPTION.
NOW YES OKAY YOUR TO PASS A ROLL
CALL 954- WIDE THIRD PARTY
DENTAL PROVIDER NETWORK ACCESS
TO PASS IS MADE WITH MINOR
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING TO MA'AM
IT'S A ROLL CALL.
THAT NINE SIXTY MY MAIN TRANSIT
A ROLL CALL 962- BURKE HOSPITAL
DISCLOSURE ON PROCUREMENT
PRACTICES DO PASSED THE ROLL
CALL. 987- ROBERT RIVAS CAL WORK
SPECIAL DIET FOOD PREPARATION
ALLOWANCE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
STRIKE THE GRANT INCREASE A ROLL
CALL. 995- TEEN TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM PLUS EXPANSION
DO PASSES MINISTRY TO
APPROPRIATION INTENT LANGUAGE A
ROLL CALL. 1-001- TEEN CHILD
CARE STRATEGIC PLANNING COUNCILS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO ADD AN
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROVIDER TO
COUNCIL MEMBERSHIP TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. TEN FOR MCCARTY
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENING SERVICES
TO PASS A ROLL CALL 1-016-
MAIENSCHEIN RARE DISEASE
ADVISORY COUNCIL HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. TEN TWENTY TWO WICKS
CALIFORNIA ANTI HUNGER RESPONSE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING ACT TO PASS
THE ROLL CALL. 1-031- IS HEARING
YOU SUBSTANCE.
YOUTH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT TO PASS AS MEDICARE
FIGHTS IMPLEMENTING CURRENT
ENTITLEMENT A ROLL CALL. 1-034-
FRIEDMAN COMMUNITY CARE
FACILITIES EMERGENCY AND
DISASTER PLANS HOLDING COMMITTEE
TEN FORTY TWO WHAT MEDI CAL HOME
A PEOPLE OUT TO TRANSITIONAL
NEEDS FUNDS TO PASS THE ROLL%
CALL. 1-058- SALAS STAKEHOLDER
GROUP ON BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INTEGRATION MEDI CAL DO PASS A
ROLL CALL. 1-061- GIPSON PLAYS
MY PRESERVATION STRATEGIES FOR
PROBATION.
SUPERVISED FOSTER USED TO PASS A
ROLL CALL 1-060- COOLEY CHILD
AND FAMILY TEAMS FOR FOSTER USED
TO PASS AS AMENDED CLARIFY THE
INFORMATION REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS A ROLL CALL. 1-088-
WHAT MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY
SAFEGUARDS TO PREVENT LOSS OF
COVERAGE TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
1-098- O'DONNELL LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OF PROP SIXTY FOUR
SPENDING TO PASS A ROLL CALL
1-105- GETS IN SICKLE CELL
DISEASE HOLDEN COMMITTEE ELEVEN
FOURTEEN AGUIAR-CURRY CRISIS
NURSERY STUDY HOLDING COMMITTEE.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO ARE WHEN
HEALTH DATA FOR COUNTY OF INTER
PILOT PROJECT YOU PASSES AMENDED
TO SPECIFY STAGE AGENCIES ARE
ONLY REQUIRED TO PROVIDE DATA.
IN A READILY AVAILABLE FORMAT A
ROLL CALL. 1-128- PETRIE-NORRIS
PROGRAM OF ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY DO PASSES
AMENDED TO ALLOW TRANSFER DATE
TO BE DECIDED BY DEPARTMENTS TO
ENSURE PAYS PROGRAMS CONTINUE
SUPPORTING LICENSURE FUNCTIONS
THROUGH.
LICENSURE FEES AB THAT
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING. ELEVEN
THIRTY ONE GLORIA MEDI CAL
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICATION PROGRAM.
CASE MANAGEMENT YOU PASSES
MINUTE TO NARROW ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA A ROLL CALL 1-136- AND
IS THERE IN CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY LIVING
HOLDING COMMUNITY.
IS THERE IN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AB ELEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN TO PASS A ROLL CALL
1-157- WHAT MEDI CAL MENTAL
HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM
CORONATION DO PASSES AMENDED TO
CLARIFY THE EQ ARE -- REPORT IS
ONLY DONE TWICE ESTABLISH A TIME
LIMIT SHOULD CONTINUE IT
CONTINUE IN.
CONTINUITY OF CARE DURATION AND
OTHER MINOR CLARIFYING CHANGES A
ROLL CALL. 1-222- FLORA ALCOHOL
AND DRUG ABUSE TREATMENT
SERVICES HOLDING COMMITTEE
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN OBERNOLTE
INTER AGENCY INFORMATION SHARING
REGARDING LICENSED IN NILES DO
PASS A ROLL CALL. 1-229- WICKS
FOOD NEEDS A FOSTER YOUTH
ATTENDING COLLEGE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE C. S. A.
C. REQUIREMENTS INSTEAD REQUIRES
CA.
AC TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON
IMPLEMENTATION A ROLL CALL.
1-224-124-06 LIMóN INSURANCE
COVERAGE OF BASIC HEALTHCARE
SERVICES TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION BY SIX
MONTHS BE ROLL CALL. 1-240-9
MAIENSCHEIN EXEMPTIONS FROM
HEALTH CARE SERVICES PLAN
REGULATION TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
1-268- RODRIGUEZ HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE PERSPECTIVE REVIEW
REPORT HOLDING COMMITTEE TWELVE
THIRTY FIVE SANTIAGO FUNDING FOR
CONSERVATORSHIP STEW PASSES
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE
APPROPRIATION MAKE IT A COUNTY
PILOT CONTINGENT ON AN
APPROPRIATION.
REQUIRE THE FIRST REPORT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS FROM INITIATION
OF THE PROGRAM A ROLL CALL.
1-287- AZERI AND NO WRONG DOOR
TO PASS A ROLL CALL 1-295- QUIRK
SILVA FAIRVIEW DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER HOLDING COMMUNITY.
THIRTEEN OH NINE BARRICADE HAND
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE ENROLLMENT
PERIODS DO PASS AS AMENDED
CHANGE THE DATES SUCH OF THE
OPEN ENROLLMENT PERIOD STARTS
NOVEMBER FIRST AND MAKES
CONFORMING CHANGES A ROLL CALL.
1-360- TING THEIR PARTY FOR
DELIVERY DO PASSED THE ROLL CALL.
1-364- BLANCA RUBIO NURSING
SCHOOL OVERSIGHT EXEMPTIONS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WAY X. CAL FOR
THIS GENERAL MEANT TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. 1-382- AGUIAR-CURRY
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING TO PASS A
ROLL CALL.
FORTINO THREE CREEL ELIGIBILITY
FOR COUNTY GENERAL ASSISTANCE DO
PASSES AMENDED TO STRIKE THE
SANCTIONS ELIGIBLE ELIGIBILITY
LANGUAGE B. ROLL CALL. 1-434-
KALRA SS I SS PICCOLA HOLDING
COMMITTEE. FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
MARK STONE CALVERT'S ELIGIBILITY
INCOME EXEMPTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE EARNED
INCOME DISREGARD CHANGES FOR
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION.
THAT PASSES WITH REPUBLICANS OF
STAINING. FOURTEEN FORTY THREE
MAIENSCHEIN MENTAL HEALTH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. 1-494-
AGUIAR-CURRY MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR TELEHEALTH IN
STATE OF EMERGENCY DO PASS AS
AMENDED WITH MINOR CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS A ROLL CALL. 1-519-
B. AND P. DENTAL BOARD.
OF CALIFORNIA SUNSET TO PASS A
ROLL CALL 1-524- DAVID CHIU MEDI
CAL PROVIDER ENROLLMENT HOLDING
COMMITTEE. FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR
GIPSON COMMUNITY PARA MEDICINE
OR TRIAGE TO ALTERNATIVE
ALTERNATE DESTINATION ACT.
DO PASSES AMENDED TO REMOVE
CHANGES.
TO THE ASSEMBLY SPEAKERS
APPOINTMENTS.
THAT GETS OUT ON B. ROLL CALL.
1-550- BONTA CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS TO PASS AS
AMENDED REQUIRE PROTOCOLS TO BE
DEVELOPED ONLY BY COUNTIES THAT
OPT TO PROVIDE EXTENDED SERVICES
A ROLL CALL. 1-557- DAVID CHIU
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
DRUG REIMBURSEMENT PILOT PROGRAM
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. SIXTEEN ELEVEN
SHOE SURPRISE BILLING FOR
EMERGENCY HOSPITAL SERVICES DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ALLOW
REASONABLE AND CUSTOMARY CHARGES
IS DEFINED SPECIFIED DOES NOT
APPLY TO POSITION AND P. IN PA
SERVICES I GET THAT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING. SIXTEEN
NINETEEN WEBER MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE FUNDING HOLDING
COMMITTEE SIXTEEN FORTY TWO
WOULD MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PLAN
IMPROVEMENT.
DO PASSES AMENDED TO INSTEAD
SPECIFIED WITH RESPECT.
TO CAPITATION READS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT SHALL TAKE THE
SPECIFIED FACTORS INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN DEVELOPING
RATES.
THAT IS HOW THE REPUBLICANS STOP
HOLDING. SIXTEEN SEVENTY SIX
MAIENSCHEIN TELEHEALTH
CONSULTATION PROGRAMS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE SIXTEEN EIGHTY NINE
MCCARTY COLLEGE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES PROGRAM HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE
CREO OWNERSHIP CHANGES FOR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO NEAR THE
APPLICATION THE BILL AND THE
REQUIRED REVIEW AND TO MAKE
OTHER MINOR CHANGES TO THE
PROCESS THAT GETS SAID ANA B.
ROLL CALL. 1-705- BONTA MEDI CAL
MERGING SEE MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT PROGRAM. TO PASS AS
AMENDED WITH MINOR TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS A ROLL CALL 1-711-
SANTIAGO DISEASE OUTBREAK FUND
GRANTS HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE SALAS
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS DO
PASSES MINISTRY APPROPRIATION
INSTEAD MAKE THE PROGRAM
OPERATIVE UPON PROCREATION A
ROLL CALL. SEVENTY TEEN SET
SIXTY SIX SPOT BELLA.
MR BLOOM I'M GIVING YOUR BILL TO
MISTER BONTA SUDDENLY HE DID
MEAN. TO SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX
BLOOM DATA COLLECTION A LICENSED
FACILITIES TO PASS A ROLL CALL
ON SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE FRAZIER
COUNTY OF SOLANO MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITIES HOLDING COMMITTEE.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY NINE DALY
RECOVERY RESIDENCES TO PASS AS
AMENDED A STRIKE REQUIREMENTS
REFER ONLY TO CERTIFIED RECOVERY
RESIDENCES STRIKE SECTION THAT
ESTABLISHES REQUIREMENTS FOR
CERTIFYING ENTITY AND OTHER
CHANGES.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING
[inaudible]
ALMOST DONE [inaudible]
HALFWAY DONE [inaudible]
READY REPUBLIC SAFETY.
I LIKE IT SMALLER WORDS HERE
THAN HEALTH.
AB THIRTY TWO BONTA RESTRICTIONS
ON USE OF PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
PRISONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY THE DIDN'T DEFINITION A
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT PRISON.
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE FORM.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE ALL THIS
EVERYBODY HAS.
PUBLIC SAFETY ARE OKAY.
NOBODY'S GOT IT NOW AB FORTY
FIVE MARK STONE INMATE MEDICAL
FEES DO PASSED THE ROLL CALL.
ONE THIRTY FIVE CERVANTES SEX
CRIMES COMMUNICATION WITH A
MINOR TO PASS A ROLL CALL US ONE
SIXTY FOUR CERVANTES FIREARMS DO
PASSES AMENDED TO REQUIRE THAT
ANY DO G. J. ACTION IS
CONTINGENT UPON PREPARATION A
ROLL CALL. ONE SIXTY FIVE
GABRIEL PEACE OFFICER MENTAL
TRAINING VOLUNTARY A ROLL CALL.
ONE EIGHTY GIPSON INSTITUTIONAL
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS HOLDING
COMMUNITY TO FIFTEEN MATHIS
DUMPING HOLDING COMMITTEE TWO
TWENTY SEVEN JONES SAWYER
RESTITUTION ABILITY TO PAY
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. TO FORTY THREE
COM MOTOR DOVE IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING TO PASS REPUBLICANS OF
STAINING TO SEVENTY SEVEN
MCCARTY PEARL CREDITS HOLDEN
COMMITTING. THREE HUNDRED KANSEN
CHILL HATE CRIME AN INCIDENT
REPORTING TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPLY ONLY TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WHOSE CRIME REPORTING
SYSTEM MEETS FEDERAL STANDARDS A
ROLL CALL. 301- KANSEN CHU HATE
CRIMES DATA COLLECTION HOLDEN
COMMITTEE THREE OH THREE
CERVANTES SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS TRIAL TO PASS THE WILL
CALL. THREE OR FOUR JONESSAWYER
WIRE TAPPING AUTHORIZATION TO
PASS A ROLL CALL 310- SANTIAGO
TRIAL JURY SELECTION DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ONLY APPLY TO
PROBATION OFFICERS A ROLL CALL.
329- RODRIGUEZ HOSPITAL SALTON
BATTERIES TO PASS A ROLL CALL
332- LACKEY PEACE OFFICER
TRAINING TO PASS A ROLL CALL
339- IRWIN GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING.
ORDERS LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROCEDURES TO PASS A ROLL CALL
340- IRWIN FARMS DO PASSES MEDI
TO CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM IN
VENTURA COUNTY A ROLL CALL. 358-
LOW SEXUAL ASSAULT FORENSIC KIDS
HOLDING COMMITTEE THREE NINETY
SEVEN CHAO VEHICLES DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE DO PASSES
AMENDED TO REQUIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT REPORT ONLY
MARIJUANA RELATED TO YOUR AYE.
REST TO DO J. A ROLL CALL. 415-
MAIENSCHEIN VICTIM COMPENSATION
TO PASS A ROLL CALL. 425- COOLEY
FIREARMS COME AMMUNITION SALES
TO PASS A ROLL CALL 517- CHEN
ORANGE COUNTY PROPERTY CRIME
TASK FORCE HOLDING COMMITTEE.
FIVE EIGHTEEN LEVINE SENTENCING
MEMBERS THE MILITARY DO PASS A
ROLL CALL 607- CREE A PROBATION
CRIMES RELATING CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE SUBSTANCES SUBSTANCES.
TO PASS B. ROLL CALL 629- SMITH
CRIME VICTIMS THE CALIFORNIA
VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD TO
PASS A ROLL CALL 662- CUNNINGHAM
CRIMES AGAINST MINORS TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. 663- CUNNINGHAM
PROSTITUTION DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO LIMIT THE APPLICATION OF FINE
TO DEFEND ITS LISTING A PROP A
PERSON UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN
A ROLL CALL. 675- RODRIGUEZ
PRISON SECURITY ASSESSMENTS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE SIX EIGHTY
KANSEN CHU PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS MENTAL HEALTH
TRAINING TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
688- KANSEN CHU FARMS VEHICLE
STORAGE HOLDEN COMMITTEE SIX
NINETY ONE KEVIN MCCARTY
INVESTIGATION REVEALED TEAMS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. SIX NINETY SIX
LACKEY COUNTY JUVENILE
FACILITIES PEPPER SPRAY HOLDEN
COMMITTEE SEVEN A ONE WEBER
PRISONERS EXONERATION HOUSING
COSTS TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
SEVENTY TWO WEBER EXONERATION
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES HOLDING
COMMITTEE EIGHT OH THREE GIBSON
PEER SUPPORT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE DO PASS A ROLL CALL.
837- HOLDEN PEACE OFFICER
TRAINING HATE CRIMES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE EIGHT SEVENTY NINE
GIPSON FIREARMS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STAGGER
IMPLEMENTATION THREE TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN B. ROLL CALL.
I KNOW ONE GIPSON JUVENILES DO
PASSES MINUTE DELETE TRUANCY
FROM THE WELFARE AND IN
INSTITUTION CODES AND MAKE OTHER
CHANGES REGARDING INTERACTION
BETWEEN PROBATION AND JUVENILES.
THE ROLL CALL I KNOW SEVEN
GRAYSON THREATS TO SCHOOLS AND
PLACES OF WORSHIP TO PASS A ROLL
CALL 917- RAY AS VICTIMS OF
CRIME NON IMMIGRATION STATUS TO
PASS.
A ROLL CALL. 927- JONES SAWYER
FINES AND FEES DEFENDANT'S
ABILITY PASSED YOU PASS A ROLL
CALL. 940-1 CUNNINGHAM CRIMES
PUBLIC RECORDS DISCLOSURE OF
INFORMATION HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
NINE FIFTY NINE MELINDA'S HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VERTICAL PROSECUTION
PROGRAM HOLDEN COMMITTEE NINE
SIXTY FIVE MARK STONE USE AN
ELDERLY PAROLE HEARINGS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO LIMIT APPLICATION
CREDITS TO USE PERL PROGRAM B.
ROLL CALL. 972- BONTA
PROPOSITION.
FOR SEVENTY SEVEN PROPOSITION
FORTY SEVEN RE SENTENCING
HOLDING COMMITTEE. TEN FIFTY TWO
KANSEN CHU PEACE OFFICER
TRAINING AND HATE CRIMES TO PASS
A ROLL CALL. 1-064- MURATSUCHI
FIREARM DEALERS HOLDING
COMMITTEE TEN SEVENTY SIXTEEN
CRIMINAL RECORDS RELIEF TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO NEAR THE
POPULATION PERSONS ELIGIBLE FOR
RELIEF THE ROLL CALL. 1-077-
EGGMAN COLLABORATIVE COURT
PROGRAMS SENATE'S HOLDING
COMMITTEE ELEVEN TWENTY TWO ONE
BARRICADE HAND FIRE ARMS AND
PROHIBITED PERSONS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. ELEVEN SEVENTY
FRAZIER PEACE OFFICER TRAINING
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
HOLDING COMMITTEE. ELEVEN EIGHTY
TWO CREO POST RELEASE
SUPERVISION OF OFFENDERS HOLDING
COMMITTEE TWELVE SIXTEEN
BARRICADE HAN ILLEGAL DUMPING
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. TWELVE NINETY
SIX GONZALEZ TRUE PROGRAM TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. 1-321- GIPSON
JUVENILE FACILITIES PEPPER SPRAY.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO ELIMINATE
THIS SECTION REQUIREMENTS AND
ALTER THE DATA POINTS FOR WHICH
LA -- WILL ISSUE A REPORT THAT
PASSES WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE
BONTA CRIMINAL JUSTICE DATA DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO LIMIT THE
AGENCIES THAT MUST REPORT DATA
TO THE DOJ.
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
1-340- GREAT CRIMINAL FINES
SURCHARGES HOLDING COMMITTEE.
FORTINO FIVE GLORIA PERMIT
HOUSING FOR PAROLEES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE
NAZARIAN DEPARTMENT STATE
HOSPITAL DESTINATIONS TO PASSES
MANAGES SPECIFIED DS AGE IS ONLY
REQUIRED TO CONSULT A PANEL
PAIRS WHEN USING A SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERT.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
OF STAINING. FOURTEEN FORTY NINE
CRISTINA GARCIA VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD ELIGIBILITY
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. FOURTEEN
NINETY SIX FRAZIER SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE HOLDING
COMMITTEE FIFTEEN A ONE LOW
FRIENDS OF BALLISTIC FARMS
PROCEDURES TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
1-603- WEEKS CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
GRANT PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. 1-636- BONTA CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE DETERMINATION OF
PROBABLE CAUSE HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
SIXTEEN FIFTY THREE FRAZIER
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE TASK FORCE
HOLDEN COMMITTEE SIXTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN JONES SAWYER CORRECTIONS
REPORTING TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REDUCE INSPECTOR GENERAL DUTIES
A ROLL CALL. 1-688- CALDERON
REHABILITATIVE SERVICE
RECIDIVISM DO PASS A ROLL CALL
1-764- CARILLO FORCE OR
INVOLUNTARY STERILIZATION
COMPENSATION PROGRAM HOLDEN
COMMITTEE SEVENTY NINETY EIGHT
LEVINE.
CALIFORNIA RACIAL JUSTICE ACT IN
THE DEATH PENALTY HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
NOW THIS ONE'S MY FAVORITE.
READY FOR SOME. SEVEN TAX BLOOD
SPILLING [inaudible]
IRATE.
WE NEED TO HELP [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
AB TEN DAVID CHIU FORMER HOUSING
TO PASS A ROLL CALL AB THIRTY
SEVEN JONES SAWYER CANNABIS
BUSINESS DEDUCTION DO PASS A
ROLL CALL RIGHT.
YEAH ONE THIRTY THREE QUIRK
SILVA PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT
PROGRAM DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
INCREASE THE THRESHOLD STATEWIDE
TO FORTY FIVE THOUSAND AND SET
IT TO INFLATION.
LOWER THE INTEREST RATE 25% IT'S
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
STILL THE COLLEGE ADMISSIONS
SCANDAL INTRODUCTION TO PASS
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING ONE FIFTY
FOR UP TO VOEPEL EMPLOYER PAID
STUDENT LOAN ASSISTANCE HOLDING
COMMITTEE. ONE SEVENTY SIX
CERVANTES SALES TAX REPORT TO
PASS A ROLL CALL 211- CALDERON
SCHOLAR SHARE DEDUCTION DO
PASSES AMENDED TO ESTABLISH AN
INCOME ELIGIBILITY THRESHOLD.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
OF STAINING TWO THIRTY FOUR
NAZARIAN SIZE MET.
RETROFIT CREDIT HOLDEN COMMITTEE
TWO FIFTY ONE PATTERSON FAMILY
CARE GIVER CREDIT HOLDING
COMMITTEE TO SIXTY THREE BURKE
TAX EXPENDITURE REPORTING TO
PASS.
REPUBLICANS ARE VOTING ON A I'M
SORRY ON A ROLL CALL. 266- CHOI
ATTIC FAN CLOSE YOUR CREDIT
HOLDEN COMMITTEE TO EIGHTY SIX
WANTED TEMPERING CANNABIS TAX
RELIEF HOLDING COMMITTEE THREE
OH EIGHT MURATSUCHI MINIMUM
FRANCHISE TAX TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. 357- IS THERE IN STATURE
LIMITATIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED
WITH TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS A ROLL
CALL. FOR FIVE BLANCA RUBIO
WATER TREATMENT CHEMICALS
EXEMPTION HOLDEN COMMITTEE FOR
SIXTEEN FONG CAL ABLE DEDUCTION
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. FOR TWENTY
SEVEN BROKE MILITARY RETIREMENT
PAY EXCLUSION HOLDEN COMMITTEE
AB SIX FOURTEEN EGGMAN FOOD BANK
TAX CREDIT DO PASSED WITH
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS.
A ROLL CALL.
MAYBE EGGMAN. SIX FOURTEEN YEP A
ROLL CALL [inaudible]
NO. SEVEN FORTY FIVE
PETRIE-NORRIS HYDROGEN VEHICLE
FUEL SIMPSON HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN PATTERSON
PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB SEVENTY FOUR MULLIN
CLEAN AIR TRANSIT BUSES
EXEMPTION.
THAT PASSES WITHIN A ROLL CALL
791- GABRIEL OPPORTUNITIES OWNS
HOLDING COMMITTEE. EIGHT THIRTY
TWO GIPSON NONPROFIT HOUSING
DEVELOPER CREDIT HOLDEN
COMMITTEE EIGHTY FIVE OR WHEN
PROPERTY TAXES IN RECONSTRUCTION
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
930- ROBERT RIVAS CLEAN AIR
VEHICLES EXCLUSION HOLDEN
COMMITTEE TEN TWENTY SEVEN PER
CALIFORNIA COMPETES DO PASSED
WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING TEN
FORTY NINE GRAYSON VOLUNTEER
FIRE DEPARTMENT EXEMPTION
HOLDING COMMITTEE. ELEVEN TWENTY
CUNNINGHAM APPAREL SECTION
HOLDEN COMMITTEE ELEVEN SIXTY
NINE FRAZIER EMPLOYEES WITH
DISABILITY HIRING CREDITS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE TWELVE FIFTEEN I THREE
OF US CALIFORNIA NEW MARKETS TAX
CREDIT HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN GROW
HOMEOWNER SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE FOURTEEN SIXTY
MCCARTY OB I PREVENTION AND
REHABILITATION ACT YOU PASS THE
ROLL CALL. 1-540-2 BLANCA RUBIO
WORKER TRAINING PROGRAM TAX
CREDIT HOLDING COMMITTEE FIFTEEN
NINETY BLANCA RUBIO FIRST TIME
BUYER TAX CREDIT DO PASS.
A ROLL CALL. 1-593- REYES EITC
DUE PASSED B. ROLL CALL 1-726-
CERVANTES CALVARY WORK
OPPORTUNITY TAX CREDIT HOLDEN
COMMITTEE SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR
DAVID CHIU MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX LEVINE
NEWSPAPER EXEMPTION HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE DOWN TO OUR LAST
[inaudible]
ONE SO WHAT [inaudible]
WITHIN.
ALL RIGHT GENERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE CATCH ALL.
ALL RIGHT AB TWENTY THREE BURKE
DEPART DEPUTY A BUSINESS AND
WORKFORCE COORDINATION DO PASS A
ROLL CALL.
SB THIRTY EIGHT WOULD WILDFIRE
PREPPER PREPAREDNESS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO LIMIT.
THE PREPAREDNESS BOARD IN
PREVENTION DESTRUCTION CRATE
STATE EFFORT TO IDENTIFY LOCAL
GAPS.
REMEMBER THE ONE BILLION DOLLAR
PREPARATION THAT GETS OUT WE
REPUBLICANS OF STAINING.
AB FORTY ONE GALLAGHER CAMPFIRE
RELIEF TO PASS A ROLL CALL AB
FIFTY FIVE EDUARDO GARCIA COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICES APPROPRIATION
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB SIXTY THREE
FONG STATE AGENCY RATING SYSTEM
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. SIXTY SEVEN
THE THREE BEST HOMELESS
INTEGRATED DATA WAREHOUSE TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE
CONTINGENT UPON.
AN APPROPRIATION ALLOW FOR OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES AT ROLL CALL
601-8 ASSESS READ WELLING UNITS
TO PASS A ROLL CALL 619- SMALL
HOMEBUILDING STANDARDS TO PASS A
ROLL CALL ONE THIRTY NINE QUIRK
SILVA EMERGENCY SHELTER NEEDS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL.
A ROLL CALL MONTH QUIRK SILVA.
OKAY.
I DID QUIRK SILVA IT WILL COME
OKAY. ONE FORTY ONE COOPER
DEANGELO TRIAL COST HOLDEN
COMMITTEE ONE SIXTY VOEPEL
VOLUNTARY VETERANS EMPLOYMENT
PREFERENCE PREFERENCE TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. ONE SAID SEVENTY
THREE CHAO MOBILE HOME
REGISTRATION TAX ABATEMENT
PROGRAM DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
EXTEND THE CENTS A DAY FOR ONE
YEAR AND RETAIN EXISTING LOOK
BACK PROVISIONS A ROLL CALL. ONE
NINETY FIVE PATTERSON EACH CD
PROGRAM REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
TO PASS A ROCK ROLL CALL. ONE
NINETY SIX CAN DOLLARS PAID
FAMILY LEAVE TO PASS WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING. TWO
THIRTEEN REYES VLF ADJUSTMENTS
FOR CITY ANNEXATIONS DO PASS A
ROLL CALL. 230- BRO DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE IS
TO PASS A WILL CALL 240-5 MERCI
DE AEROSPACE IN EVERY AVIATION
COMMISSION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CONSOLIDATE REPORTING REDUCE
COMMISSION MEMBERSHIP.
AND ADDRESS CONFLICT OF INTEREST
CONCERNS A ROLL CALL. 240-7
DOLLY CAR FIRE RELIEF TO PASS A
ROLL CALL 265- CHOI JUDICIAL
CANDIDATE INFORMATION VOTER
GUIDES HOLDEN COMMITTEE. TWO
SEVENTY FIVE RAMOS NATIVE
AMERICAN CULTURAL PRESERVATION
TO PASS AS A MAN AS AMENDED TO
LIMIT THE NUMBER STATE AGENCIES
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
289- FONG CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT ON ARMS BUDGETS MEN.
ON CHáVEZ PERSON THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. 312- COOLEY
REVIEW A STATE GOVERNMENT
REGULATIONS HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
THREE THIRTY EIGHT KANSEN CHU
SMOKE ALARMS EMERGENCY.
PREPAREDNESS AND MOBILE HOMES
AND MANUFACTURED HOUSING TO PASS
AS AMENDED REDUCE REQUIRED
TRANSLATIONS THAT GETS OUT ON
THE ROLL CALL. 340-5 CALDERON
NEW BEGINNINGS CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM TO PASS THE ROLL CALL
351- CHOI PAYMENT OPTIONS FOR
CRIMINAL FINES AND FEES HOLDING
COMMITTEE THREE SIXTY QUIRK
SILVA.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VETERANS
CEMETERY DO PASS A ROLL CALL.
371- FRAZIER STATEWIDE ECONOMIC
ASSESSMENT OF THE FREIGHT SIX
SECTOR HOLDEN COMMITTEE THREE
SEVENTY SIX MARK STONE STUDENT
LOAN SERVICING DO PASSES MINUTE
WITH TECHNICAL MEMON SECOND SET
ON BE ROLL CALL. 393- NECESSARY
AND FUNCTIONAL RECOVERY STANDARD
IN CALIFORNIA BUILDING CODES TO
PASS A ROLL CALL FOR SEX Là
MùT DISABILITY COMPENSATION
PAID FAMILY LEAVE APPLICATION
NON ENGLISH LANGUAGES TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. FOR LEVIN MARK STONE
CITY OF SANTA CRUZ REDEVELOPMENT
BOND PROCEEDS TO PASS WITH
REPUBLICANS OF STAINING. FOR
SEVENTEEN ROBERT RIVAS ROLE
AGRICULTURE DO PASSES MINUTE
DELAY MAY PROVISIONS REQUIRING A
NEW SICK MY REPORT THANKS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL. 419- EGGMAN.
I THOUGHT THAT MY A MAKING OF
WORDS [inaudible]
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
STANDARDIZATION PROGRAM TO PASS
A ROLL CALL 429- NAZARIAN
BUILDING INVENTORY DO PASS A
ROLL CALL. 434- DALY UNIVERSAL
APPLICATION WERE EACH C. D.
HOUSING FINANCING PROGRAMS DO
PASSES AMENDED WITH TECHNICAL
MEMONS A ROLL CALL. 437- WOULD
MOVE IN LOAN PROGRAM TO PASS THE
ROLL CALL 457- KILEY ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE COMMISSION REPORT
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. FOR SIXTY SIX
DOCTOR EGGMAN FARM TO FORK TO
PASS A ROLL CALL 474- RAMOS
CAPITAL ACCESS LOAN PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE FOR SEVENTY
SIX BLANCA RUBIO.
RUBIO LICENSEE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOREIGN TRAINED PROFESSIONALS DO
PASSED B. ROLL CALL. 477-
CERVANTES AMERICA EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS TO PASS A ROLL CALL
FORTY SIX LOW MOAN ANIMAL
WILDFIRE GRADUATION HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. FIVE EIGHTEEN
PETRIE-NORRIS STATE PUBLIC WORKS
BOARD.
DO PASSES AMENDED TO STRIKE THE
CONTENTS OF THE BILL AND INSTEAD
AMEND THE ACCOUNTS RECEIVABLE
MANAGEMENT ACT TO REPEAL MAKE
OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. FIVE THREE NINE
RAMON CONSUMER LOANS TO PASS THE
ROLL CALL 540-4 BRO INACTIVE
PROFESSIONAL LICENSE FEES AN
UNPAID RENEWAL FEES HOLDING
COMMITTEE. FIVE FIFTY FLORA
VETERANS MEDICAL FOSTER HOME
PILOT PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. 567- CALDERON LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. 571- MULLIN CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS TO PASS B. ROLL CALL 572-
KALRA CALIFORNIA DEFORESTATION
FREE.
AN ACT TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
DELAY THE TGS CODE OF CONDUCT TO
DATE BY ONE YEAR THE ROLL CALL.
594- SALAS ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TO PASS AS AMENDED
DELETE THE PORTION BILL THAT
CREATES ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
COMMISSION THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS OF STAINING. SIX
THIRTY FIVE BIGELOW FAIR GALA
FAIR GROUND VEHICLE INSURANCE TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. 640-2 Là
MùT LEE GENERATORS TO PASS THE
ROLL CALL 637- EGGMAN COMMERCIAL
FEED SAFETY TO PASS.
A ROLL CALL 668- AND SALAS
COURTHOUSE PRIVILEGE FROM CIVIL
RESCUE PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL
671- FRIEDMAN SS THREE DWELLING
UNIT BUILDING INCENTIVES TO PASS
A ROLL CALL. 677- CHOI.
INTER COUNTY ADOPTION FINALIZED
IN A FOREIGN COUNTRY TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. SIXTY ONE AND SALAS
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY LACK
ELECTIONS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS TO CHANGE THE TIME FRAME
WHEN THE NOTICES MUST BE SENT
OUT. TO BETWEEN A HUNDRED TWENTY
AND THIRTY DAYS BEFORE ELECTION
AND TO ADD EMERGENCY CLAUSE THAT
GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL. 684-
LEVINE BUILDING STANDARDS FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE PARKING DO PASS
A ROLL CALL SINCE SIX NINETY
FOUR IRWIN VETERANS HOUSING AND
HOMELESS PREVENTION BOND ACT TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SPECIFY THE
BOND AMOUNT IS SIX HUNDRED
MILLION A ROLL CALL. 717- IS
THERE AN ARMORED CAREER SERVICES
HOLDING COMMITTEE. SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR WICKS RENTAL PROPERTY DATA%
REGISTRY HOLDING COMMITTEE SEVEN
FORTY TWO CERVANTES PLACE BASED
ECONOMIC STRATEGIES ACT HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. SEVENTY SEVEN GIPSON
VOTER REGISTRATION INFORMATION
TO PASS THE ROLL CALL. 800- CHAU
CIVIL ACTIONS CONFIDENTIALITY TO
PASS A ROLL CALL 816- QUIRK
SILVA CALIFORNIA FLEXIBLE HAVE
HOUSING SUBSIDY PULL PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE EIGHT THIRTY
ONE GRAYSON H. CD STUDY OF
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING AND LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT FEES DO PASSES
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE
RESIDENTIAL FEE.
BURDEN REPORT REQUIREMENTS THAT
IS HOW THE REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. EIGHT FORTY NINE
BONTA LOCAL REDISTRICTING DO
PASSES AMENDED TO NARROW THE
BILL TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
REDUCE THE NUMBER PUBLIC
HEARINGS TO FOREIGN CONSOLIDATE
HEARINGS WITH REGULAR BOARD
MEANS THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. 857- DAVID CHIU PUBLIC
BANKS. TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ELIMINATE SPECIAL DISTRICTS MAKE
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT APPROVED THE
VIABILITY PLAN AND MAKE IT PART
THE D. B. O. APPLICATION.
AND ELIMINATE AGENCIES AND SMALL
COUNTIES UNLESS THEY FORM A GPA
BACK IT'S OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
859- MAIENSCHEIN DEPENDENCY
JUDAS JUDICIAL CASELOADS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY JUDICIAL
COUNCIL NOT CREATE A NEW
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND MADE RELY
ON EXISTING DATA THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. 861- CHEN
JUVENILES TO PASS AS AMENDED
INCREASED AMOUNT OF TIME FOR
WHICH A SOCIAL WORKER MUST TAKE
ACTION FROM FIVE TO TEN DAYS
CHECK IT OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
891- BURKE SAY PARKING PROGRAMS
FOR HOMELESS PERSONS DO PASSES
AMENDED TO EXCLUDE COUNTIES WITH
A POPULATION OF LESS THAN THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND OR LESS.
ALLOW EXISTING PROGRAMS RUN BY
NON GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES TO
FILL THE REQUIREMENT THAT COULD
HAPPEN TO BE ROLL CALL.
AB NINE OF SIX COOLEY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PLAN HOLDEN
COMMITTEE NINE THIRTY ONE BURNER
**** BATH WOMEN APPOINTMENTS ON
LOCAL BOARDS AND COMMISSION DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT GETS
OUT ON THE ROLL CALL. 958-
AGUIAR-CURRY ORGANIC FOOD GRANT
PROGRAM HOLDEN COMMITTEE NINE
SEVENTY ONE SALAS PUBLIC
CONTRACTOR IN VALUATIONS IN CALL
COMPLETION BONUSES TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE BONUS
PROVISION THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. 976- CHAO ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND STATE
GOVERNMENT TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
986- ROBERT RIVAS.
DISADVANTAGED FARMER GRANT
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE TEN
TEN EDUARDO GARCIA INDIAN
RESERVATION AND RANCHERIA ACCESS
TO SEE HOUSING PROGRAM DO PASSES
A MINUTE AS AMENDED TO STRIKE
THE CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION.
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
1-020- IRWIN STATE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING HOUSING AGENCY ACT
HOLDING COMMITTEE. TEN THIRTY
SIX AGUIAR-CURRY CIVIC OUR
REGION VOTER ENGAGEMENT TO PASS
AS AMENDED DELETE THE TEN
MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
1-066- GONZALEZ UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE TRADE DISPUTE TELL
JILL BIT ELIGIBILITY FOR
BENEFITS TO PASS THE ROLL CALL.
1-092- JONES SAWYER CHILD
SUPPORT ENFORCEMENT TO PASS THE
ROLL CALL 1-104- CALDERON
CALTRAIN LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE GUARANTY ASSOCIATION
TO PASS A ROLL CALL. 1-113-
CHILL DAVID JAIL OFFICE OF
IMMIGRANT REFUGEE AFFAIRS
HOLDING COMMITTEE ELEVEN SIXTEEN
GRAYSON FIREFIGHTER PEER SUPPORT
TO PASS A ROLL CALL 1-117-
GRAYSON PEACE OFFICER PEER
SUPPORT TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
1-130- LEVINE PERSONAL
INFORMATION DATA RECENT BREACHES.
TO PASS AS A MAN TO CLARIFY THE
DEFINITIONS OF BIOMETRIC DATA IN
GOVERNMENT IDENTIFICATION
NUMBERS THAT GETS OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL. 1-133- LOW BEER GLASS
WHERE DO PASSES AMENDED TO ADD A
SUNSET IN ADD RECORD RETENTION
REQUIREMENTS LIKE IT'S OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. 1-157- FIRST TIME
DEPOSIT PROGRAM REPORT HOLDEN
COMMITTEE LEVIN SIXTY FIVE
BARRICADE HAND CHILD BECAUSE
SUPERVISE.
SUPERVISED VISITATION DO PASS A
ROLL CALL LET IT VENN EIGHTY
FOUR GLORIA PUBLIC RECORDS
RETENTION.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO LIMIT THE
RETENTION REQUIREMENTS TO JUST
EMAIL THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. 1-200- PATTERSON
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTION ACT
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. TWELVE A TWO
CHAO PRIVACY DATA BRIT BROKERS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES B. ROLL CALL
1-217- BALLING CAMPAIGN
DISCLOSURES TO PASS THE ROLL
CALL. 1-240-2 IRWIN INFORMATION
SECURITY HOLDING COMMITTEE CALL
FIFTY THROUGH THREE ROBERT RIVAS
LASKO GRANT PROGRAM TO PASS BE
ROLL CALL 1-255- ROBERT RIVAS
LOCAL SURPLUS STATEWIDE DATABASE
TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
TWELFTH ANY MARK STONE FALSE
CLAIMS ACT TO PASS THE ROLL CALL
1-279- BILLION HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT HIGH RESOURCE AREAS
DO PASSED THE ROLL CALL 1-288-
COOLEY CANNABIS TRACK AND TRACE
TO PASS A ROLL CALL. 1-306-
CRISTINA GARCIA MISUSE OF FUNDS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE THIRTEEN TWELVE
LOW COLLEGE CONCERTS CONSULTANTS
ACT DO PASSES AMENDED TO STRIKE
THE RIGHT REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENTS AND INSTEAD REQUIRE
THE SECRETARY STAY IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE DC AGE. TO
RECOMMEND A REGISTRATION PROCESS
TO LEGISLATURE BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THAT IT'S HAD
ON A ROLL CALL. 1-332- BONTA
SANCTUARY STATE CONTRACTING
INVESTMENT ACT HOLDEN COMMITTEE
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIXTEEN CANNABIS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS RETAIL
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS ACTIVITY TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO CHANGE THE
RATIOS. TO ONE FOR EVERY SIX
LIQUOR LICENSES ONE FOR EVERY
FIFTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT
GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL.
SIT -- THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE WHEN
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE PROGRAM TO PASS A
ROLL CALL 1-357- BIGELOW DEAD
AND DYING TREE REMOVAL HOLDEN
COMMITTEE THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
SANTIAGO COURT REPORTER FEES TO
PASS THE ROLL CALL. 1-391- BONTA
ELECTIONS VOTER LANGUAGE
PREFERENCE TO PASS A ROLL CALL
1-417- BLANCA RUBIO CANNABIS
ADVERTISING MARKETING DO PASSED
THE ROLL CALL 1-437- CHEN
PROPERTY TAX OVERRIDE RATES FOR
PARAMEDICS TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
1-457- I'M SORRY FOURTEEN FIFTY
ONE LOW PETITION CIRCULATORS DO
PASSED ROLL CALL 1-464- GREAT
CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY AUDIT
TO PASS A ROLL CALL. 1-471-
GREAT STATE REIMBURSEMENT A
PREVENTABLE LOS REVENUE HOLDING
COMMITTEE. FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE
CERVANTES OPPORTUNITIES OWNS
HOLDING COMMUNITY FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE GRAYSON STATEWIDE
HOUSING DATA PORTAL TO PASS.
THE ROLL CALL. FOURTEEN A
SIXTEEN LOCAL AGENCY SURPLUS
LAND DO PASSES AMENDED A LIMIT
THE SCOPE AND MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES BE ROLL CALL. 1-487-
CHAU HOUSING LINES FOR THE BAY
AREA TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SPECIFY THE APPOINTING AUTHORITY
THE GOVERNING BOARD AMONG OTHER
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS BE WILL
CALL. 1-499- FLORA COMMUNICATION
SYSTEMS GRANT PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE. FIFTEEN TWENTY LOW
COURT REPORTERS BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA DO PASS A ROLL CALL
1-521- LOW CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
ACCOUNTANCY TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
1-450-152-2 LOW BOARD OF
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LANCER
MAYORS IN GEOLOGIST TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. 1-523- LOW STATE
ATHLETIC COMMISSION TO PASS A
ROLL CALL 1-531- SALAS STATEWIDE
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES HOLDING
COMMITTEE FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR
WAY X. REGIONAL HOMELESS ACTION
PLANS HOLDING COMMITTEE. FIFTEEN
FORTY FIVE OBERNOLTE CIVIL
PENALTY REDUCTION HOLDEN
COMMITTEE FIFTEEN FORTY GABRIEL
NONPROFIT SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM
TO PASS A ROLL CALL 1-576-
CALDERON SECRETARY OF GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS WORKING GROUP TO PASS.
IT'S CALLED YEAH CALDERON.
YEAH A ROLL CALL.
YEAH IT IS FIFTEEN EIGHTY LEVINE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES FOR MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS TO PASS A ROLL CALL
SIXTEEN A ONE RAMOS CAL -- YES
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HOLDING
COMMITTEE SIXTEEN THIRTY ONE
GRAY VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTER
TRAINING HOLDING COMMITTEE
SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE DALY MOTOR
VEHICLE INSURANCE FRAUD HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. SIXTEEN NINETY SIX
CHAO INTERNATIONAL TRADE
INVESTMENT OFFICE TO PASS A ROLL
CALL 1-702-3 OF US HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL DO PASS A ROLL CALL.
1-708- RODRIGUEZ EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TRAUMA KIDS HOLDING
COMMITTEE SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
FRIEDMAN TAX INCREMENT FINANCING
HOLDING COMMITTEE. SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE BURNER **** BATH
SHORT TERM RENTALS COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO COASTAL ZONE DO PASSED THE
ROLL CALL. 1-736- DALY LOCAL
AGENCY NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS
FOR CONTRACTORS TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. 1-740-2 SANTIAGO CREEN
AMERICAN NATIONAL MUSEUM HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE
CARILLO IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS
TO PASS THE ROLL CALL 1-754-
JONES SAWYER OLYMPIC SECURITY TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. 1-783- ROBERT
RIVAS STREAMLINED APPROVAL FOR
AGRICULTURAL PLAY HOUSING TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SHORTEN THE
NOTIFICATION TIME FRAMES.
B. ROLL CALL 1-784- SANTIAGO
OPEN SOURCE VOTING SYSTEMS TO
PASS BE ROLL CALL. EIGHTEEN NO
ONE EGGMAN CATTLE DO PASS A ROLL
CALL EIGHTEEN A SEX CERVANTES GO
BIZ INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
HOLDING COMMITTEE EIGHTEEN OH
SEVEN CERVANTES SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE COMMITTEE.
EIGHTEEN OH EIGHT CERVANTES
SMALL BUSINESS AND DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
PROGRAM.
DO PASS AS AMENDED REQUIRE
COLLABORATION WITH A DISABLED
VETERAN PROGRAM THAT GETS ON A
ROLL CALL EIGHTEEN NO NIGHT'S
RUN HIS DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE IS TO PASS.
A ROLL CALL.
AC ONE AGUIAR-CURRY VOTER
APPROVAL THRESHOLD FOR LOCAL FOR
BY HOUSING PROJECTS TO PASS THE
ROLL CALL.
BOB RIGHT.
NOW IF YOU'LL BEAR WITH ME
[inaudible] TWO YEARS.
ALL RIGHT I'M AS YOU NOTICE
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF BILLS
THIS YEAR THAT WE DID NOT CALL
OUT INTO ARE MISSING YOUR BILL
THERE'S A REASON WHY WE HAVE
ALWAYS HAD THE ABILITY TO MAKE
CERTAIN BILLS TO YOUR BILLS WE
HAVEN'T UTILIZED IN WHEN WE HAVE
WE HAVE.
UTILIZED VERY OPENLY.
THIS YEAR BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY BILLS.
MANY THAT WERE EXTREMELY GOOD
BILLS ARE HAD VERY GOOD IDEAS
BUT NECESSITATED A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS OR LATE AMENDMENTS IN
ORDER TO MAKE THEM WORKABLE OR
AFFORDABLE -- OR THAT THERE WERE
JUST SOME OPEN ISSUES THAT
DIDN'T ALLOW US TO MOVE THE
BOARD WE HAVE MADE THOSE INTO TO
YOUR BILLS -- I WANT PEOPLE TO
KNOW THEIR WELCOME TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THOSE BILLS WITH OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF AFTER SESSION IS
OVER LIKE IN SEPTEMBER -- BUT
THE FOLLOWING ARE ARE BILLS THAT
WERE MOVED TO TO YOUR BILLS.
AB THIRTY ONE CRISTINA GARCIA AB
EIGHTEEN LEVINE AB TWENTY FOUR
BURKE AB ONE FORTY CERVANTES AB
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN LOW AB TWO
THIRTY EIGHT SANTIAGO AB TWO
FIFTY NINE CALDERON.
AB TWO NINETY ONE SHOW AB THREE
TWENTY SIX MURATSUCHI AB FOR
THAT. THREE FORTY FIVE MAYOR CG
AB THREE TWENTY TWO GALLAGHER AB
THREE SIXTY THREE GONZALEZ A. B.
THREE NINETY FIVE BLANCA RUBIO
AB FOUR OH EIGHT FRAZIER.
AB FIVE THIRTY THREE HOLDEN SB
FIVE SEVENTY SIX NAZARIAN SB SIX
FORTY SIX MCCARTY SB SIX FORTY
EIGHT NAZARIAN EIGHT B. SIX
EIGHTY THREE CARILLO AB SEVEN
THIRTY TWO BONTA A. B. SEVEN
NINETY LEVINE.
AB EIGHT EIGHTEEN COOLEY AB --
EIGHT TWENTY TWO WHEN.
AB EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT EGGMAN AB
EIGHT FIFTY FOUR MAYES AB.
EIGHT NINETY ONE AB EIGHT NINETY
SEVEN MEDINA EIGHTY NINE NO
EIGHT O'DONNELL AB NINE SIXTY
FOUR MEDINA AB ELEVEN FORTY
STONE OAK AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
WHAT.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE MARK
STONE AB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX
BURNER **** BATH A. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTY EDDIE GARCIA AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY FIVE BLOOM AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT MCCARTY AB SIXTY NO
EIGHT HOLDEN.
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO BLOOM AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX LIVING IN
AB TWELVE SIXTY TWO O'DONNELL
AND THOSE ARE THE BILLS THAT ARE
MOVED.
IF YOU CAN HOLD FOR ONE MAN I
THINK WE HAVE SOME CHANGES
.
ALL RIGHT -- THERE THERE ARE
[inaudible]
MIGHT.
I AM DYSLEXIC SO APPARENTLY.
I SAID AB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN JIM
WOOD THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE JIM WOOD.
IT WAS AN H. H. S. DOCUMENT AND
IT IS THEY DO PASS AS AMENDED SO
I MISS READ THE BILL NUMBER.
IT IS UP AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
WHAT DO PASS AS AMENDED.
OKAY WAIT WE HAVE ONE OTHER
CHANGE THAT WE'RE GONNA AN OUNCE
AB THIRTY NINE AMERICA SU CHI WE
READ OUT AS REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING THE REPUBLICANS ARE
ACTUALLY VOTING AND LIKE IT'S
OUT ON IN A ROLL CALL.
THOSE ARE THE CHANGES THAT WE
MESSED I'M TERRIBLY SORRY THE
COMMITTEE IS MADE FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO BILLS ON THE FLOOR I
THERE'S DO PASS OR DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS THAT REPRESENTS
ABOUT 65% OF THE BILLS -- AND
THAT REDUCED OUR OVERALL COST
FROM THIRTY POINT SEVEN BILLIONS
AND ONE TIME AND I'M GOING FUNDS --
TO AROUND TWELVE BILLION THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THAT CONCLUDES
OUR PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING